Five speeches.
She already three,
two,
one.
Yeah.
I don't know who makes this weed,
but fuck you.
Whoever it is.
Some strong might say this is some Ed
Rosenthal.
Wheat Grass.
Yeah.
We went deep.
He went to the deep end of the pool.
Dude.
Dude,
dude,
just back from Brooklyn.
So we would recap this,
but before I want to congratulate Eddie
Bravo and becoming five foot nine and
it's huge.
The modern medicine.
Big Difference between five,
eight and tell me about it.
I'll kill you.
Can Tower over people who are compressed
discs.
You literally get.
I mean when you look at old people and
they're all fucked up like that,
that's really what's going on.
They're shrinking because their disc
tissue,
the Chinese,
the Chinese say you're as old as your
spine.
Oh,
electronics people.
That makes sense.
It's true.
They say cool shit.
I like fortune cookies.
Just attributed a billion people.
As I got a billion people say it's.
It came from somewhere and try to from
one guy I ordered a laptop and a.
I got the package and it came straight
from China and it just sinks.
It sinks in,
you know,
especially when you get something that's
from a country like China,
like there's only one reason why they're
making something in China.
There's one reason,
well there's two reasons.
One,
because they'd make a lot of things
there,
so the manufacturing tolerances are very
high.
They make when iphones,
things along those lines,
but also because you know,
people are going to work for cheap and
lived there.
Like when you get a laptop,
like there's a real thing you do,
will you like,
you know,
you don't want to live the way that
people who made this live.
Right,
but you're going to get it anyway.
I'm going to get it anyway in any way
because you can go one click on the
apple store and sensors.
It's fucking weird.
Works though.
Seven cents to make your last name.
China.
China's actually,
because they've made so much money now
they're workers are demanding way more,
you know,
sort of higher salaries also like better
work,
natural bed.
Guess what?
Guess what's going on now for the day,
but they're losing jobs now.
A lot of Chinese manufacturers are gone.
You're now got to go to South America
and Malaysia and we got to Vietnam.
We can.
These guys would work for even less.
So.
Chinese workers are losing jobs to
fucking Malaysians and the economy.
He's led apple.
They run such a tight ship.
They had put nets down.
So many of the workers were committed
suicide nets.
Yeah.
To company called Foxconn.
Foxconn is the company that makes all of
the laptops and they make a gang of
apple products.
I think they make phones to,
to to make a bunch of shit,
but they literally have nets are on the
roof and here's the best part.
So many people committed suicide that
they had to address it and they their,
their,
their argument was,
well,
you have to understand these people live
here.
So if you look at the number of people
in consider it like a population.
The suicide rate is very similar.
Wait a minute,
you can play with stats.
They live in the factory basically just
slave slaves.
Slaves were slaves.
Have you ever noticed later,
but they're getting an
iphone stick getting money.
They're getting money.
They can leave when they want money in
the concentration camp.
So no,
they didn't.
They definitely didn't get money in
concentrated.
You don't.
You don't have to be there.
You can leave whenever you want,
but this is all they're going to give
you and you're going to work 16 hours a
day or whatever the fuck did you ever
know that's legit slaves.
No matter what.
Would you want pennies.
That's real.
Slavery and I phones come from this.
Are you sure that you got here?
How do we allow that?
Here's the question,
right?
What you want your mom to be working
there?
Would you want your wife to be working?
But what it means,
that's all she could do.
She could just put together and that's
what she's going to.
A dollar a dollar an hour is better than
no money in our Joe Rogan is.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
You definitely right.
And,
and by the way,
what's interesting about China is that
they do have a huge middle class as a
result of their industrialization and
all the suffering they went through in
the eighties,
nineties,
they,
you got what?
$400,
million middle class workers now who are
buying things like cell phones and flat
screen tvs and all kinds of stuff.
You know what's fascinating to me though
is that when was,
if you,
and I'll wait for when you can tell me
when was the last time you bought
anything made in Russia,
like wow,
that's a good point.
But just if you could please just vodka
vodka socks and we don't.
And by the way,
I don't know if it sucks,
but we,
we don't have,
we use the American Swedish Baka being
paid off by Bella tour before this fate
or event.
Somewhat.
Some anti marketing strategy fate or
Russia of doom.
They're basically a one crop economy
man.
They make great box oil,
you know,
isn't that nice?
Well,
they were held back for so long,
like communism doesn't fucking work.
Kids,
it doesn't work.
And here's the little dust that either
as a monarchy,
which it is now with bizarre like Putin,
you can't,
your private property means nothing
because the government can come along
and go,
uh,
did you say something about me will take
that over?
Let's take them over and throw him in
jail,
and so he was going to open a business.
What about first don't let make and God
makes first bro,
and it's supposed to stay on the animal.
Thank you.
Piece of shit.
Supposed to stay on the animal.
That's called virtue signal that you've
got that.
Great.
The population are very disciplined
people.
It's a.
it's a.
it's actually a really colorful culture
that created a lot of art and the
Russians are smart people.
Everything else they are and they
produced a thing.
I'll tell you what,
I'll tell you what they produce
motherfucking ass kickers.
Yes they did.
They got some serious ass kickers come
out of Russia.
Who's running boxing right now?
Good Nautica,
Lufkin surgery.
Koval live says,
I thought search.
I love Andre Ward,
but I thought surgery.
Kovalev won that fight.
He dropped them.
Me Constantly
press the attack.
I just didn't think that.
I didn't even think it was that close.
I was really sweating the Soviet.
The Russians are so macho.
The Russians are matched their
patriarchal society.
So if you think about food and he hunts
tigers.
He's on the,
on the,
on horseback with his shirt off.
He,
by the way,
I have to say this because people always
correct us,
like Loma Cenk goes from Ukraine,
different close as it obviously you see
that,
but that's like saying Canada and
America.
It's so close,
but it's not.
It's North America.
Bad motherfucker who's skating up in
Canada,
some unbelievable hockey player.
Do you consider American say North
American?
You consider him as a guy?
He's a Goddamn Canadian.
You know he is going to kick your ass.
He's.
He's over here to play hockey.
Better.
More,
more importantly,
sir,
off of Wayne Gretzky.
More importantly,
don't forget that the Ukraine and Russia
proper,
it was annexed by the Soviet Union,
the Union of,
but it was essentially Ukraine has
always considered themselves sort of not
part of the Kremlin.
They've always considered those own
country and I would remind people that a
guy,
nice guy named Joseph Stalin,
a starved the Ukraine and about eight
and a half million people died of
starvation because he essentially
collected forcefully,
collected all of their crops and for a
thousand reasons and they all about
eight and a half million people
scenario,
but the size of the Midwest.
United States is like a Goddamn history
teaching.
Great on fucking video series.
Oliver Stone,
the uh,
what is it?
The something's history of the United
States,
a secret history of the United States
that what it's called,
something.
It's fucking amazing.
I don't watch this.
You know,
Oliver Stone is a real history fanatic
and he,
I mean,
it must have been exhausted.
The untold history of the United States
is that it sounds like literacy to me,
Eddie.
It's Fuck Eddie.
You want to look at conspiracies,
like,
look at the way the world really works
and forget all the nonsense.
This,
this is fucking fascinating and all
proven,
all.
Like you could watch the videos of the
people saying what they're saying.
You could see what happened after World
War Two,
like,
oh,
what's one thing?
People out just just horrific fucking
history that we have in the world of
people just going into other countries
with their armies and killing groups of
people and just the amount of times that
it's happened over the history of the
United States when Oliver Stone is like
laying it all out with the footage.
Damon told history,
the United States,
so fucking fat Americans taken over
everybody taking over everybody.
It's Hitler.
When Hitler was pushed into Poland,
when Hitler was in Africa,
like all these,
the whole thing,
it's chaos.
The history of people is the history of
people taking over giant chunks of land
and fucking things out.
We just haven't experienced that over
here.
We were so young.
This country is souls fucking young.
It's crazy when you watch this
documentary,
when you realize like,
oh,
this calm is like a very rare moment
where the ocean is still before tidal
waves come smash.
Those tidal waves are going on all over
the world right now.
If you're in Syria right now,
you are watching missiles flying into
apartment buildings.
You're watching suicide bombers,
if you're in Afghanistan,
you're watching all kinds of chaos all
out of the throughout the world.
It's just not happening here,
so we're being loled.
We're being called to this false sense
of what a human being is.
Fascinating.
Also is that you to in order to
galvanize armies,
to to go see a peak in the fear though
on us into that room,
but you galvanize young arms,
you galvanize armies around what around
ideology,
around things like communism is the best
way to go.
Fascism in is best way to go.
Christianity is the best way to go.
Islam is the best way to go,
and those armies have to have something
they're fighting for.
So that's what's fascinating about.
If you read the Old Testament man,
it's literally about.
It's guys like you guys are fucking
worshiping false idols.
I got to send the Babylonians and
obviously the rockies,
you know,
destroyed the Solomon's Temple in 586
BC,
which was the Jews built their temple.
That was their most sacred thing.
The Babylonians,
you know who they are.
They're the Iraqis that they.
Iraqis,
Hipaa fucking footprint.
A historical footprint that's so much
bigger.
It's crazy.
The original civilization as far as
modern historians.
Which uniform first?
Mathematics?
Yes.
I'm writing for.
Is these weird.
It looks like an old school nails.
You know what an old nail looks like.
You ever work in a bill?
You ever do construction?
Uh,
no.
When I was a kid we did a lot of
construction in Boston.
A lot of those buildings are really old
and a lot of the really old buildings,
they have a different kind of nailing
them.
It's a handmade nail.
So instead of looking like a circle with
like a straight line,
what they look like is like a wedge.
It's like a hard,
like flat.
It's not round at the top.
And they would say that's what the
cuneiform looks like.
Pull up an old nail though.
Pull up an old old construction nail.
They looked like a wedge.
Four sides.
So that's what a cuneiform.
There it is.
See those,
those nails?
Well that's,
that's kind of a rotten out one.
There you go.
See how they looked like it looked like
a wedge.
See they're,
they're like a little sword more than
they are like around rounded cylinder
type thing with appointment.
Oh,
those are all handmade to make.
Yeah.
Well they used to have some sort of a
mold to it,
but you would go to a blacksmith or
whoever the.
No,
those are ironman.
Yeah,
I would imagine they're stealing.
I think it's great.
I think it's copper.
No,
Brian,
trust me,
those are rusted.
They're old.
That's iron.
That's 100 percent iron.
You see all that rust on it.
Copper doesn't rust.
I got.
Those are all they have.
That's how they would make those.
My Dad was um,
he was,
my Stepdad was a architect so I got a
lot of jobs on construction sites.
Like that's what I did through high
schools to have a job.
Dude,
lets you know you don't want to work.
I'll tell you that for a week,
dude.
I did an in a fucking building in the
summer.
So we're,
we're building this house and I'm the
kid who has to carry the insulation
upstairs.
Then put it in the Cox and people do
that.
They don't want to listen to me.
They do not like it was bruce.
We'll do that tomorrow.
Yeah.
A lot of people would do that and you
get it in your skin and you can't get it
out.
Get it your stuff.
Yeah,
and you have to wear a marriage class.
You've got to wear a mask because you're
breathing it in because as you're
putting that stuff up,
it's flying in the air like you would
see the light would come in from one of
the windows and you would see like all
these particles in the air.
You're like,
well,
it's terrific.
Look what I'm breathing.
The worst thing,
the worst job I ever had with tearing a
house down in Washington dc in the
summer and then we take it and bring it
out to Lawton landfill and you'd have to
cart it off and then we poured the base
for a bill,
like a big apartment or a building,
actually a house.
The base with cement and stuff.
You have to dig that kind of work.
I remember going there,
there is no fucking way I'm going to
stay in college.
I'm going to figure out a way to not
ever have to do this.
It was the worst shit in the world and
you wake up early for some reason.
When you work construction you,
you're.
You're up super early and you're driving
in a truck.
Yeah.
Now stop and think about someone in
China making your iphone exactly 10
times worse,
10 times worse.
Living in my photo,
doing construction,
making the iphone.
They're just doing the same everyday.
The monotony.
Working with these machines,
they demand productivity.
What kind of food are you getting there?
It's got to be terrible.
If you're forced to live there and
you're getting terrible food,
they're all packed together like
sardines within what?
The loop for when this country.
We have the same thing on hog slaughter
farms and things like that.
There's a routine to it.
With all those people working there,
I'd go crazy.
Oh my God.
See you all.
Dress the same.
Chairs are super comfortable.
That crazy.
Come on,
man.
I want to work there.
You would go crazy and you don't see
Madison that like you look at suicide,
suicide nets.
Look at all these people stacked in
together and these little tiny
dormitories,
housing,
dorm rooms.
You think guys get really good at like
missing the net.
Just you gotta just jump further.
Just run like a Jackie Chan off the top
of the roof.
Stoked.
I bet they're trying to get a look at
Japan who've seen the subway.
They push you on that.
Push people.
I've been there where they did that to
us like we're in rush hour and I wanted
to go down there to see what it was like
and you get shoved to bring that up.
You'll see the film in one day.
They paid dudes in uniforms to shove you
in like a for real.
This is happening right now.
I hadn't happened to me.
It was just.
I was like,
well,
you know what's amazing is how uniform
people's behavior is in Japan and how
like people are so polite and calm and
they get along well in Japan they had to
because a lot of people in a very small
area.
We feel the next trade was done.
Guys trying to push people.
Is there a similar train come and run
up?
They can't.
They can't have any more trends.
This is every day one push.
Push that fucker get in there.
You start dating your motherfucking so
ridiculous right now in Japan.
Imagine if you are preparing of so
that's just not in their pants.
Every time they ride on that thing,
can't wait to get published in Japan
where you get a lot of guys who rubbed.
The big difference is that China or
Japan?
Japan.
Japan is like incredibly populated but
really small,
but I think Japan did we decide to do.
We measure that is the most $5 million
and it's very small.
Camp people die on the side of New York
City and skip on Japan like I dunno how
big Japan is.
How I might've made that up.
It's not the size of New York.
Tokyo is the size of New York City.
Right,
but Japan itself in California,
how big is it?
That makes sense,
but it's an hour or two.
There are a lot of their different
Tokyo.
Thirty 5 million people though.
He swept that stacked into this little
spot and they're super orderly.
8 million.
When Curtis Lemay was firebombing Tokyo,
I believe about 8 million people in
about eight days died from fire.
I think it was 8 million or maybe it was
a million,
but I don't get shit in the Oliver Stone
things.
What happened in Russia?
That's the dark.
What happened?
Twenty 7 million people died in World
War II.
Twenty 7 million people,
man,
and it's very rarely discussed.
And then how many Russians died?
Two and then they had stolen the next 10
years.
They last.
Yeah.
They had more people died in World War
II than anybody.
Yes.
No one talks about it.
One as well.
Dude,
very flatland.
This flat area,
the Oliver Stone thing,
it's overwhelming.
I'm going to have to watch it like three
or four times and wasn't there.
This was world war two,
but wasn't there only a 2 million deaths
total from like that must most of them
from soldiers.
Fifty dollars million.
Most of them were civilians.
That deaths there are about 50 million
altogether or maybe more from a total in
the world and World War Two.
You know what I'm talking about?
Just soldiers though.
I think 2 million soldiers,
12,
there's probably a lot of civilian
death.
I mean there were firebombing killed.
Most of the deaths by far were civilian
according to what I saw.
I must have caught.
There was a lot of civilian deaths,
100 percent because there was a lot of
fire bombing cities like just
indiscriminate firebombing,
especially in Japan.
Like we did some horrible shit to them
before we dropped the atomic bomb,
but even before we dropped the atomic
bomb,
they were fire bombing cities.
You know,
they,
they killed everybody that was down
there.
Like the nuclear bomb itself,
like if you mean that is so crazy that
they were willing to drop.
I mean this is where a war gets.
You're willing to drop a bomb on a city,
not a military base now,
and because we're weird because Nagasaki
and Hiroshima,
remember where I'm the industrial cities
that we're churning out a lot of the war
planes and there was.
That was where the center of their war
machine was to remember.
We drop pamphlets,
we dropped my uncle,
my great uncle dropped the pamphlets,
the warning pamphlets saying we're going
to do,
we're going to fucking drive.
Is better surrender that here.
Yeah.
They gave them warning,
which that's how crazy nuclear power was
and meanwhile they had only blown up
shit in the desert and you know,
and stuff in the ocean before they
really weren't sure what was gonna
happen.
We didn't know.
A lot of scientists didn't know that
there was energy trapped in an Adam and
and when we,
when they actually detonated the
hydrogen bomb,
we were like,
wow.
All the theorizing about energy and
anatomy.
In fact,
that is actually true because we just,
that's,
that's kind of proof positive when you,
when you see a mushroom cloud with that
kind of power and you're like,
oh fuck.
We just unleashed the horrors of nature,
which is crazy because we've been in war
ever since we've had those things ever
since.
No one's gotten to the point where that
comes out.
Everybody's like,
just keep it on the edges.
Come on,
bitch.
Oh yeah.
There's a term for it.
Mutually assured destruction.
Yep.
Matt can be broken down into an acronym.
Yeah,
your boy,
Sam Harris and Jordan Peterson had a
really fascinating discussion about they
couldn't really get out of the gates
because they couldn't agree on what
truth was,
but that was a frustrating discussion.
Very much so.
But,
but at,
they had a fascinating idea of there are
certain things that you could know
scientifically that none of us should
know.
And for example,
there are scientific truths that if we
knew would actually result in our
complete extinction.
Like what?
Like,
you know,
uh,
so,
so an example of when we found out if
you split an atom,
it creates a chain reaction and a
powerful force that can vaporize 100,000
or even a million people,
right?
There is potentially scientific
knowledge like that that could have,
for example,
reduced everything that you know to dust
and if that's something that's actually
something you could know,
is it worth knowing and would it be
immoral to know you know,
that that's Kinda the,
that's where morality and science kind
of converge and where you have an actual
conversation about certain things are so
devastating and it would be the.
It would mean the end of your entire
existence.
So maybe that's a scientific truth,
quote unquote that isn't worth having
even though scary.
Yeah.
But the problem is the universe doesn't
give a fuck about that.
Correct.
The reality is if someone does invent a
time machine and they hit that button,
we're all fucked.
I mean,
it really could happen.
It really is something that's,
you know,
within a thousand years,
whatever,
you have the exponential increase in
technology and power and with what's
available and what they can do.
It could happen percent.
That's why it's so important to have
those discussions.
You,
that's why you know,
the atomic bomb,
there was a real concern that it was
going to evaporate the entire atmosphere
of the earth.
It was,
it wasn't everybody,
but there was a small group of
scientists to go,
hold on,
you know,
what else could happen?
This could kill everybody.
And they were still like,
we'll see what happens.
We don't think so.
Think about,
think about like,
think about responsibility for a
scientist like that.
Think about that idea.
But how about the,
when they had the first nuclear reactor,
who was it?
Who was the Italian guy?
The father of the nuclear reactor
though.
So,
and they were at the University of,
Oh fuck,
what was the university?
Where were the,
I guess the reactor started overheating.
I don't.
Jesus.
And they had a,
the,
there was a guy with a bucket there who
was just going to throw a bunch of water
on it.
I mean it was,
I can't.
I'm Frederick Frederico,
Enrico Enrico Fermi.
There it is.
What a name.
That's what it was.
Thank you buddy.
And she named was in Rico University
Chicago.
It started to trip out.
I would wear only handmade suits.
My name is Enrico Fermi,
enrico handmade shoes.
It was loafers with no socks.
He was a genius.
I think he died of radiation poisoning,
didn't he?
Because he might have ingested it.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Poor bitch.
From the time they started the Manhattan
project,
how long did it take to actually figure
out the atom bomb?
That's also in the documentary that's in
the documentary because we're trying to
figure it out,
man.
It was if we could split the atom and
hit critical mass shit,
can you imagine what kind of a weapon
this would be?
So it was a.
They hired a couple thousand scientists.
They started the Manhattan project,
started throwing all this money at it,
right?
And then the final proof was Nagasaki
and Hiroshima.
That was it.
Did we pull this off?
And then boom,
they knew already that it works because
they had a bunch of tests before.
Uh,
before they did that,
one of the most horrific thing about the
test was they would have soldiers run
towards the blast because they didn't
understand radiation back then,
which is so incredible.
Like they didn't understand the damage,
radiation,
those videos you could watch online,
Jamie [inaudible] up,
or they would blow this atomic bomb up.
They add up.
I'm a mock town in the distance.
They would create these mocks cities to
see what kind of damage it would do.
They'd put up houses and Shit and they
blow them the fuck up and they'd have
these soldiers run towards the blast.
And the idea would be that after the
blast went off,
it killed whatever.
People are killed and everybody else
would be stunned and that's when the
soldiers move in so they would fucking
crazy towards the bottom.
It's the funniest video.
They're all dead.
They all showed up.
They think that that's what killed John
Wayne soldiers running to nuclear
explosion.
Yeah.
Punch that.
And that's what you just said.
Well,
it's like a plan.
Days after we dropped that bomb does
bombs on Japan.
When Hirohito,
the emperor got on the radio and said,
called for the surrender.
One man said,
it's time for us to surrender every
single soldier.
One of the Japanese.
Everyone I'm willing to die for that
cause they.
They dropped their weapons and they
surrendered it.
We took what they were so fanatically
devoted to authority and still in many
ways are so check this shit out man.
These fucking are sitting there watching
that in the distance.
I mean did that close and what's crazy
is like the wind from the blast comes
and hits them.
There's a bunch of different videos of
this.
A lot
of these were the US army would document
a lot of their training episodes and so
this is what they would do.
They'd get see that?
That's the blast from the nuclear bomb.
Look at that.
Fucking people are standing there in
these trenches and there's a bomb going
off in the distance.
It's so scary that they knew so little
about what effects it would have on
people and they let these people run
towards their death and these people are
all running towards radiation sickness
running towards cancer.
They're running towards this fucking
mushroom cloud in the desert.
Was that the repercussions?
Like when they got home that night,
people would feel like there's a bunch.
If she'd been.
You'll never get the full fucking story
as to what happened and what kind of
health problems,
but John Wayne died because he was
filming these Spaghetti Westerns in the
fucking in the desert in Nevada near
these test sites and a lot of people
that were on the crew with them.
This might be bullshit.
A lot of people in the crew with them
got cancer.
Look at it.
He got lung cancer.
No,
no,
no.
It was the government who got lung
cancer from smoking.
Yeah,
he did.
Everybody in the film.
There was something about everybody on
the film that worked on that film with
them also smoked and also to cancer.
What the fuck?
How long did it take?
How long does nuclear bomb goes off?
Like just a nuclear bomb just went off
before you get sick.
How long have you have to wait until you
could populate that area again?
Dozens of years.
Not necessarily going to take your
Sheila knocking SOC report.
Not as bad as like nuclear waste.
Nuclear was the atomic bomb,
so waste.
It's a.
it's a different thing than the thousand
years it would take for that.
No,
no.
To take that long.
People live in Nagasaki now.
They live in Hiroshima in their
factories with the nuclear waste.
There's definitely plants,
nuclear power plants that have nuclear
waste it.
That stuff gets to like what's going on
right now in Fukushima,
it's very,
very dangerous because they can't do
anything about it yet and it's getting
worse.
Like the radiation levels are higher and
Fukushima now than when they've been
battling this disaster since what?
Two Thousand and 12,
something like that.
Turnover turnover is a fascinating
example of a major nuclear meltdown and
it's thriving with wildlife thrive.
Nuclear Wolves.
Yeah.
Shane Smith from vice films show out
there.
Really?
Yeah.
They were fucking hunting wolves with Ak
47 commute and mute and wolves.
And read your mind Bro.
Don't ever play rock paper scissors with
them.
These fuckers know what's coming.
You know,
there's people that think that they
never figured it out.
They never figured out how to make the
atom bomb and they just basically
firebombed just like they did all the
others.
Those people are retarded.
There's peer reviewed papers,
but we were in a war.
We were in a race with the,
with the Nazi's to create a bomb.
We knew the Nazis,
the moon,
because there are a lot of German
scientists came over.
I remember as as for example,
Einstein.
Am I getting confused here?
Are you suggesting that nuclear aren't
real?
I don't know.
I'm just saying there's people that
think no,
but they never figured it out.
Those people retarda 100 percent.
They ever targeted Dude Oppenheimer
Oppenheimer's papers that he wrote on it
and the work that he did on it,
like that's all anybody could read that
anybody can go into that.
It's all documented.
What they did,
the tests,
I mean they.
There's videos of the explosions,
there's videos of them blowing a fucking
hole in the ocean.
That's so insane that they had these
boats,
these destroyers placed around the
water.
They didn't pull that up because I
forget what the test was with the
nuclear testing.
The ocean.
There's videos of bombs going off.
You can see it.
It's real destruction.
Undeniable.
How do you know their nuclear,
not just regular bumps.
The difference in the destruction is
insane to me.
Eddie fucking God.
Dude,
you're talking about a mile high wall of
water.
They had no idea it was so scary.
If you're a fish,
know they lost his fucking boat.
They're like,
well,
we'll just have this boat.
Sit around.
Look at it.
This.
We're getting a new monitor.
This monitor keeps cutting out.
I don't know what's going on.
Terrifying.
It destroys this fucking boat.
They thought they could park their
destroyer a certain distance away from
this nuclear bombs.
So they're like,
okay,
so if we drop a bomb on them,
how close can we be?
Turns out you can't even be remotely
fucking close.
Check this shit.
How you see it from the sky.
Look at this.
Watch this.
They set up this fucking boat.
I mean,
when see Jamie,
what are you doing?
You're fast forwarding.
See if there's got to be a part where
you can see it from distance because
from distance it's so fucking insane.
That's what it looks like.
You're talking like,
what is that?
30,000,
40,000
plus feet in the air and water,
Bro.
Dude,
that's insane gas,
so the water evaporates.
Irregular bomb can be the way that is
hundreds of thousands of regular bombs.
What they can do with these things is
insane.
Crazy at Nagasaki and Hiroshima or
little firecrackers compared to what
they have now.
Fire fighter aircraft,
so it's just not a question whether or
not nuclear power nuclear bombs are
real.
There's nuclear power.
That's probably the reason why we're.
Our lights are on or that we use nuclear
power as as we speak,
but what it does make steam.
Yeah,
I know.
It's very clean.
It's very fucking hot as fuck and it
makes steam as long as it doesn't get
out of your little holding pen.
It's like you've harnessed a demon and
you use that demon to make tea.
That's right.
Cattle,
the power.
That's so unbelievably hot.
The constantly keep water in contact
with it.
It makes steam.
The steam powered the turbines.
The turbines make electricity gets out.
Yeah.
Well a piece of uranium,
I think the size of a pencil,
you can look this up,
can run a nuclear for six months.
You know,
it's an incredible,
insane form of energy.
It's a demon and we're harnessing it and
a cement box and we're putting it right
next to the ocean drive to San Diego.
You have a drive to San Diego and see
the nuclear power plant there and all
the nuclear bombs and that Russia had.
They still have to have.
That's one of the great things about
where lost shit though.
There was a lot of lost material.
Nuclear Bomb,
Rosa parks and the rosenbergs soul.
No one else figured it out.
The American.
Did you ever hear that American story?
So the story.
So the.
The rosenbergs a husband and a wife sold
nuclear secrets to the Soviet because
they were communists in this,
in this country,
and when they sold them,
and was it truman?
I think Truman put them to death in the
electric chair.
They both.
They were both killed for bait for high
treason,
but now those motherfuckers sold it to a
lot of people in India just pull my
amount each other.
Remember this too,
as they're the rise math Semitism in the
thirties in Germany and certain
scientists and Jews were getting
assassinated,
beat up a lot of the German scientists
because there was a real renaissance in
Germany and Austria,
physics renaissance at with along with
people like Albert Einstein.
They emigrated to the United States
because they were like,
I don't think they liked the Jews over
here,
and in Germany.
We benefited from that mass immigration.
We've talked about this guy on the,
on the podcast before,
but the biggest crazy scenario,
like ironic scenario was Fritz Haber,
the guy who simultaneously was winning
the Nobel prize for being able to
extract nitrogen out of the air at the
same time.
They wanted to try him for crimes
against humanity being the first one to
gas people and he created Zyklon a,
which was this really fucking horrible
smelling pesticide.
It was a terrible poisoned,
but it had a horrible smell to it and
that smell let you know that it was
there.
The Nazis took it and turned to design
con be they took the smell out of it and
they use it to gas.
The Jews and this guy was a Jew himself
and a scientist dude,
but he was a painter in the country.
He's a patriot.
He wanted to help his.
He wanted to help Germany,
his beloved country,
when World War One and said,
I think I can help you guys with a gas
that will kill everybody,
a lot of people and we'll just wait for
the wind to shift and he was a patriot
in his mind.
He was killing the enemy who are trying
to take over his country.
He was a Jew and then of course in 19
while starting my God and probably 39,
they started using this gas.
What happened to him in the final sweep?
Wound up dying,
fleeing Germany,
and he had a heart.
He had a heart condition.
His life was hell man.
His wife committed suicide in front of
him because of what he was doing like it
was.
It was off and he left his son with his
wife's body while he went off to war to
go do more of it because.
Right.
The whole
thing is it's.
It's just the.
It was a different place.
It's a different world.
It's not Santa Monica where you're going
to fucking starbucks and you get some
sugar free latte.
People will always starved.
We had to worry about the winter and we
have to worry about Guano.
We relied on Guano on bat shit and bird
droppings close to Chile.
People will go to war,
get bat shit.
Do you know that?
That's where the term crazy.
That's where it came from.
Not In Africa.
People would go to these places in
Africa to take Guano and other people
will come from other countries.
They would go to war over this stuff
because it's the best fertilizer you
could use.
You just have to get nitrogen into the
soil.
But Fritz,
Fritz Haber and his buddy and the guy
who had perfect this came up with a way
to get nitrogen out of the air which
becomes ammonia and that's how you know
drips into a liquid form.
This can right out of the air dude,
so we don't die of starvation anymore.
Modern Day farming and the reason you've
never met anybody who died of starvation
is because of Mr Fritz hopper.
You better start getting more grateful
for real high because you're just
laughing.
In general,
they say that 50 percent of the
nitrogen,
50 percent of the nitrogen and the human
beings today might have come from the
hopper method to estimate.
Shout out to harbor to hopper.
The air that you breathe in is like 80
percent nitrogen.
We think of it as oxygen and carbon
dioxide.
It's mostly nitrogen.
Yeah,
just really weird.
That's why pure oxygen fucks you up and
gets you high and it's dangerous.
Right,
and super good.
Super flat.
When you're.
When you're looking in bars in vegas.
Everyone's trying to.
I had one Jack Shit for me.
Anything.
They so stupid.
Have you been scared?
I was.
Fuck that.
You got to do it.
You'll never leave.
You almost died.
I went to.
I went to fucking look at the biggest
nuclear explosion ever equals to 57
million megatons of TNT.
You tell him he just wants to bomb.
It's like way bigger than its source.
That's in the atmosphere member who
signed the antibody testing training and
the air atmosphere at that.
That's incredible.
Kennedy and the Soviet signed a pact to
not do this in the atmosphere and what
James is trying to toss it in the Arctic
Ocean.
When they did this in 1961 bomb ever
tested.
God.
That's like the final scene in a video
game.
When you win for them where they made
these movies,
they made them in Hollywood at the
lookout mountain studios.
You could look that this is not not made
in Hollywood.
Eddie.
This is a video of an actual bus.
Kennedy and the Soviet real.
I'm just saying they edit it and had the
biggest studio lookout.
Mountain studios.
It was a.
It was a top secret air force
intelligence as the one we were talking
about up in some dude who works at the
video store edit it.
Who would have edited that would go to
someone who is the biggest,
most advanced movie studio saying that
that's fake.
No,
no,
no.
I'm just saying that they admitted it.
They.
That's where they put on it and they
edit it together,
but they didn't change it.
They just filmed.
I almost died when he dropped that.
Everything,
everything,
everything.
Everything.
In any anti treat,
anti testing,
treated the atmospheric testing,
I can't remember how to word it,
but he looked out the window and said,
well,
we're weren't detonating these bombs in
the atmosphere.
Where's that waste co?
And they were like,
um,
it just rains down on people.
He goes,
well,
that doesn't make any fucking sense
because we're all.
When we were doing it,
the Soviets are doing it,
can we?
And that's when they signed the treaty
not to do that anymore.
They don't,
they don't test nuclear weapons.
Nobody knows anymore.
Nobody does.
But Russia did launch some sort of a
missile test recently.
Two Treaty apparently saw getting very
scary mountains.
Very gangster gangster.
Well he's,
I watch house of cards,
Bro.
Pretty much get it.
Putin's created an atmosphere again,
you know,
he's just a product of symptom of the
Russian mindset maybe.
But like I said,
he's a hard man.
Hard,
hard man who makes his country weaker.
When was the last time you bought
anything Russian?
So what's going on?
You know,
I mean,
it might not be a soft time for Russia,
but it's a soft time for us.
Clinton.
Obama said something interesting,
he said,
let's just just just we can ignore
Russia.
They make guns and some oil,
but their guns aren't even that good.
Nobody needs him.
You know.
Obama said that he didn't really say
like stabbing yourself in the finger on
the edge.
Brother.
I live on the air knife or definitely
not the edge.
He's quoting.
Knife came from the Congo and it's
probably got all sorts of diseases like
justin wren probably hit that in his ass
over here.
Just stole that from a poor kids.
Gold in fucking jail.
Me My shift.
That's what you would use.
Feels like.
It feels to me like your fingers would
slide right up on the blade.
One.
Good Stab and you cut your hand.
Not The way I hold her brother.
What do you put your thumb over the top?
First of all,
like a pen.
You go and click.
Click.
When I,
when I.
When I yard fight,
when I get into a yard.
Shanking fest.
I'm slicing.
I'm opening you up.
I'm fucking.
I'm unzipping.
My other friend is actually like studied
like knife fighting,
fighting techniques and what these guys
do know,
I catch him video to like butter,
the slice.
You open like butter on zippy.
I'll scribe your spine from the front.
I kind of go,
I can't do this.
Adult opened you up to rather pay taxes.
Let's show me a video on Instagram,
doodling.
Look,
this guy dead lifting 600 pounds.
Just.
I'm like,
oh my God.
My friend John Rollo was sending me,
showing me some pictures on his phone,
went to lunch other day and he was
sending me some pictures on his phone
with his duty trains with who's a week
just to put 100 percent natural tested.
Many times I'll have to see it,
homie
is he's dead lifting some ungodly amount
of weight like 700 pounds or some shit
from behind his back behind his back
behind himself and lifting us up and
he's showing this to me and he's got.
He had 600 pounds on his back for a
squat with no hands.
He puts his hands like this and he does
a full deep knee squat.
Six hundred pounds resting while he's in
a prayer position.
Yeah,
yeah.
No hands.
He's just.
That guy can do with like a bar by
itself.
This motherfucker's got like 600 pounds
and squatting like this.
He's insane.
Big Country Fed,
white,
gray and black guy.
Giant athlete.
The naked gorilla to my left over here.
You said according to your brother,
you got to over 700 pounds.
Yeah,
but not.
This is one of those asshole.
This guy's 1:40
world records.
Four zero.
Oh my God.
He's just a freak and Rollo was telling
me about it and he's like,
dude,
I'm telling you.
This guy looked breaks almost every and
he's not like the heaviest class.
So sometimes he competes against people
who are heavier than him and in those
cases he doesn't lift as much or
anything.
It's just really good at this saying,
I forget his name was just unbelievable.
Physical strength.
This is what these guys are into.
Like Mark Bell,
you know Chris Bell documentary maker
and his brother mark from bigger,
stronger,
faster.
These fucking guys,
they just.
There's videos or their whole
instagram's like videos of them pushing
a new personal record.
They got their fucking elbows all
wrapped up and everything is wrapped up
and mark's actually get this thing
called a slingshot that you put your arm
and it's like this thick rubber neoprene
thing that you bench in and he's
benching 600 clapping and it's great.
It takes to get into that suit slapping
each other which powder and chalk in the
air at all they're trying to do is just
like lift heavier and heavier weight.
It's crazy.
I love it.
I take a weight lifting class now with
from an Olympian,
you dumb fucking Venice at the Venice
barbell holiday was.
I saw you try to deadlift and Austin had
died.
So sad.
I though.
Oh,
that was when he was doing like four 95.
That primal soldier dude,
that dude from instagram,
it's just ridiculous.
Kettlebell routines.
He's one of the instructors and this guy
is just stupid strong.
And he was dead lifted.
It was like 4:50
plus 100 pounds of chains,
right?
Yes,
yes,
yes.
So it's like 50 slash 50 if you get to
full.
We don't really get the full chain,
you know,
some chain left.
But he's a young warrior who likes the
chain.
It was great with that damn sap.
Do they always works out in the shortest
shorts?
No shirt on.
Fuck.
Like that.
Body double chicks around the body.
Now you're thinking about Juan's brother
pizzas.
Too much ticket.
A primal soldier.
That's who he is on.
There is no,
that's,
that's Eric.
I think that's the wrong dude man.
That's his brother.
His brother.
But one is a based.
His brothers.
I just saw him.
Oh is that the same guy?
Now I'm talking about the other guy who
wears glasses.
Just go to primal.
Swole.
Go to go to tim level.
Soldier.
Go to his um,
his instagram page.
His view of it.
Noticing that like when you try to click
on instagram pictures from a Mac,
sometimes they don't open up a new
window.
The kid maybe it's a different spot so
far.
Yeah.
Go to the upper left.
One kid is doing because I could Ninja
Turtle.
John Wolfe work me out on it when I was
there and Austin Goddamn fucking shitty
computer screen.
We've got to get a new TV.
This TV does not communicate with our
computer.
Right,
but he does all these like flow
exercises.
Shorts couldn't be smaller and go out
and publish.
Shout out to short,
short,
front,
jacked his.
Fuck God damn stupid young warrior and
his brother Bell Swing and stud.
Clotted up.
His brother.
One is the other head instructor there
and forget it.
I would never wear a shirt with John
Wolf is the shit to.
John Wolfe gave me this whole hip series
of workouts.
He gave me this hip thing.
It's all body weight exercises.
Just extending your foot forward.
You do like 10 reps that way and then
you do 10 reps like as a side kick to
the side and hold it out in the air and
then you do 10 reps left and then 10
reps right in front of you like you did.
Circles did a whole dinner with amazing.
Unbelievable.
Then he had me take.
John said,
let's just look.
Yeah.
I said,
I ask them a question about the mace,
and he goes,
yeah,
and he grabs a 15 pound mason.
I'm like,
dude,
I'm a lot stronger than 15 pounds.
Give me a hug and bray.
Okay,
yeah.
Uh,
we did five rounds of some crazy shit
and 15 pounds was simply perfect.
It was worth.
And I told him about.
I workout with a 25 pound club.
You know those Indian male clubs,
those 25 pounds steel club,
that's it.
Twenty five pounds.
That's it.
But when you're doing shit like these
things,
were you swinging over your arm like
Conan and just hold it in place.
It's phenomenal exercise and you realize
our biggest weaknesses,
the things that are always going bad on
people,
and that's the connections.
That's not necessarily your biceps,
right?
It's usually like the connection between
your bicep and your shoulder,
your shoulder to your back,
attended our connections.
And when you're doing things like yoga
and when you're doing things like these
club bells,
we holding these big steel clubs in
front of you and you're swinging them
over your head.
You're developing like very strong
tissue and all your shoulder joints in
your elbow joints,
in your wrist joints because it's
constantly manipulating the,
the,
the different and it's kinetic,
the different weight of it.
I mean the,
the gravity is pulling it this way in
that way and you have to stabilize it
and you're using all these weird muscles
that you don't use if you're pushing a
nautilus machine and we're just doing
something simple like a ranch.
Yeah.
You got these isolation things where
like you're holding one thing and you're
moving it in a certain way by itself.
Like whether it's Kettlebell flows or
whether it's.
I'm using steel clubs like you're
controlling like all of your different
stabilizing muscles in,
in a very unique way.
Holding static positions to do that one.
It's like a yoga exercise where you're
on one knee and he had one leg straight
out and
your arm straight ahead and just hold
that.
I just started doing yoga and that I
have a whole new respect for yoga.
I mean I've been doing it now three
weeks and man it kicks my ass.
It's an hour and at the 30 minute mark,
I'm Don.
I got to leave.
I walk out.
Have you ever been to yoga class that I
haven't walked out.
Really?
Yeah.
It's so hard to bring ice water.
I do break down after 30 minutes.
I get crushed.
Crushed in 30 minutes.
It depends on how your body and then I
laid there and it's so God damn hot.
It's like 110 degrees in there.
It's ridiculous to stick it out.
I have no choice.
I have no trust.
Every day I'm looking at.
It feels like you're getting it done.
I actually am proud of myself for going
because that's the hardest yoga class.
They got a core yoga.
They got all different kinds of levels.
No heat at all.
Little bit of heat.
I didn't even know it was an accident.
It was just perfect.
Ten 30 in the morning,
wake up.
I just go,
go right down the street and it was just
kicking my ass from day one,
just crushing our early hang.
I leave there and I got to.
I'm too tired to get in the shower.
I was just like,
are you good with the Cold Eddie?
Can you handle the cold better than you
hit cancel the heat?
Yeah,
but I want to kill two birds with one
stone.
I want to stick it out and I want to be
able to.
I mean,
there's old ladies that do it,
you know what I mean?
And they're fine and just holding,
holding your arms up and all these
poses.
No wonder yoga chicks have big shoulders
and triceps.
You're sexy.
Oh Man.
All those poses that look,
they look so easy in a picture that
looked like,
oh,
they're doing tight.
She tried doing.
Try Holding your hands up for a 90
minute class.
That should a test.
You know our your hours enough.
For me,
I do 90 minutes every week.
Sometimes I've done it three times in a
week,
but I'm doing it at least once a week.
Sometimes I do.
There's a 70 minute class that they do
there.
Sometimes it's really good because they
don't talk at all.
It was just like,
you know,
it's for people that already know the
positions just tells you what to do.
Go through it.
No,
no,
no.
She cheats.
Says like begin and,
and she says what the position is to
begin,
but none of that explaining what to do
while it's going on and there's a
little.
There's like some,
some yoga places,
not the one that I go to,
but I've been to some when I start
talking about like the mystical
properties in this position.
This is good for the ascending colon.
No know you didn't go to medical school.
Did I take.
I take classes down in Venice and there
will be some awesome,
awesome.
Like good looking dude who would come in
and beads and a great body.
He was a Yogi.
I.
There's one guy,
can't remember his name.
He's the greatest.
He would teach and the girls all loved
him and he would adjust you and I swear
to God he would.
You'd get into a position and he would
say,
and let's not fight this.
Let's just have our own relationship
with our own God.
And there it is.
Love,
feel how much energy it does take to
reach to the back of the room and had a
great voice.
And I'd be like,
I was like,
I'm with his voice
to give myself over to la.
Was that I haven't been back since I was
at this hot yoga.
I won't say where it was a 90 minute
class and there were,
for whatever reason that day,
that morning,
there's just hot chicks everywhere.
And it was,
this dude comes in and the girl dates,
we goes,
he's strict.
He's known for being strict and like,
well two yogis with relapsed.
We go in there.
Oh Dude,
10 minutes into it calls me out.
Brennan,
eyes up front,
let's not,
let's not go.
No,
swear to God,
you know,
I'm fucking balls deep.
Get My,
you know,
my hamstrings.
So it was,
it was unwarranted.
Yeah,
hundred percent.
And it was super embarrassing.
I was like,
Hey,
call blocking.
Yeah.
Hey,
you know,
I'll punch in his face because I was
switching legs and I didn't know what
everyone else was doing.
I was so into it.
And so I looked around to see what they
were doing.
He's like,
eyes up front,
running,
eyes up front.
Let's not go.
Let's not.
God make me so mad because I would be
talking with a shitty thing to say if
you weren't actually doing that.
Do you think he's just hating?
I'm not sure what's going on.
I haven't been back.
Kind of hurt my feelings.
Well,
there was a guy that used to teach yoga
at my place and he was like real sort of
hardcore,
like a very like intense dude and he,
you know,
he would teach the class was a,
it was headed at a totally different
vibe to like,
I got along good with them,
but his vibe was different.
You know,
his,
his vibe was like,
you're like,
you're gonna have to tough this out.
Military style was a little weird.
I was like,
yeah,
come on man.
We're just stretching.
That's how this guy with any to calmed
down,
I don't want to be aggressive.
And this guy was saying,
he goes,
uh Oh,
you can only get water when I totally
get water.
And he goes,
once that door shuts,
no one can leave this.
Did that to fucking.
I don't like that.
There's a guy,
Brian cast,
who is one of the more famous guys.
He was really smart about it because he
opened up his school in Los Angeles.
He studied for many years and he said,
uh Oh no.
Are All,
are welcome,
and there's no money and be like,
what?
And he goes,
just donation if you want no big deal to
have that.
Yeah.
And you just donate.
But he made millions because what
happens is people go all the time,
they're like,
it feels good.
Yeah.
You're like,
you're not even asking for money.
The class is open to everyone first come
first serve totally democratic.
And what you do is people don't like
taking shit for free.
Most people,
most people are like,
you know what?
I'm going to give you a 100 foot because
I really appreciate.
I would do that.
Like I,
I give the NPR because I listened for
free all the time.
So whenever news from ketamine,
hey,
how bout we talk about the fights?
The Bikram Yoga Guy got fucked right
with me.
Like trying to rub his boner on girls
and stuff while he was alive.
That yeah,
apparently on the ground in a cold,
a Rolls Royce and he had a speed on.
I mean,
I've been to is they,
uh,
they asked him about it,
he says lies,
lies,
and then,
and then he said women would have paid
$1,000,000
for one drop of my sperm.
And The
lady was like,
what?
He goes,
one drop of my sperm,
$1,000,000.
And he was just saying that they're,
they were liars and the salt nonsense,
he was a bad ass.
His wife was shit.
He drove around in a Rolls Royce.
He made millions of dollars.
He would.
He was the one who came up with hotbox
yoga.
Yoga,
right?
Well,
not really.
Well apparently they had been doing that
in the,
even in the same positions for the
longest time.
Well India.
So anyway,
he promoted it in the United States in a
big way.
Yeah.
He'd be a bodybuilder.
He used to lift weights.
It was checked.
Yeah.
You've seen those pictures of him back
when he was young.
He was jacked.
He's 70.
He would yell at you.
He's swinging Dick and given out fucking
back massages.
Everybody's in there in a speedo.
Oh yeah.
The greatest.
He's a bad motherfucker.
He was wearing that to scare the guys
away.
Like,
you know,
I'm just scared.
I used to take class.
How you.
It's so hot in there,
man.
You want to wear something like that?
You don't want to have anything on.
It's so hot.
I wear a little shorts.
Short shorts,
like a primal soldiers shore too.
That's what I work on my site where I
like to wear the Zoomba board shorts and
a and a roots of fight tank top.
You don't wear a shirt?
No,
it was too hot.
Too Hot.
I'll come to one with no one in my
class.
Wears a shirt.
Chicks have to though.
They have to wear more poor girls.
Yeah.
But uh,
yeah.
They're all in bikinis.
Did poses like through the whole deal.
Do the hotel.
It's no joke.
It's not easy.
And hour and a half I'll get to you.
It's you gotta hydrate.
You gotta hydrate in them.
When I get up in the morning,
as soon as I get up,
I start drinking water.
Big guys drink a lot of water for.
I get there.
I'd take a bunch of shroom tech,
eat some fruit,
10,
15,
and just get in my car.
Thirty minutes.
You've got to prepare for that shit.
Like it's an ordeal.
So fucking sandy's sitting in them
squats.
But I'll tell you what,
mack's done wonders for my back.
Wonders for my flexibility,
wonders for my joints,
like joint pain.
It's the shit.
And for your brain to man and at our age
we have no choice.
No,
You have to do yoga.
I mean,
unless you want.
You want to be that guy that's 75 and
can walk on his hand,
check out on your own or be that 75 year
old that just get to the anger.
Anger.
Yoga is no joke.
Bring up by younger.
Uh,
take a look what he's doing at 70.
Take a look at this motherfucker.
It's,
how do you say his name is?
Anger.
Anger is what it spells.
Now I'm sorry,
I a y a n G U Y E N G he's no fucking
joke dude.
This motherfucker does.
Is He your new boyfriend?
No,
he's an older.
Yes,
but he,
his students shows now homophobic.
Congratulations.
What have you done to take a look at
this motherfucker?
What he did when he was younger?
The poses he would hold at 75.
I'm trying to find him that guy.
Oh,
okay.
It's stupid.
And He.
How old is he now?
Is he dead?
Oh No,
come on.
Our full dad bod.
Fuck you a great gonna.
Succeed.
Fuck his buddy.
His buddy's.
If you an extra seed,
let him just rub all over him.
But he would do some crazy shit.
Dude.
This is the guy you're telling me.
So impressive title right now.
Watch this though.
Brian is not impressive.
Flat Ass Watch.
Watch the shit he does.
I'm watching when he was really all he
was doing scorpion.
What does that look at that versus.
But Bro.
Dude,
this is 76 before people sick.
Yoga.
My Yoga teacher would fuck this guy into
the ground stretching.
Okay.
I don't think you were correct because
that's right.
There is pretty good.
He does way hanging to the side of.
The thing about this guy though is he's
built like a popsicle stick and when
you're built like a popsicle stick you
can put your body into weird positions
because you don't have any muscle to
stop it.
Like there's certain poses,
you know,
this one where you go under the arms and
you can't do it.
It's not happening.
It's just too much meat and I'll keep it
right here joe.
Keep it right here.
Try it though because even in trying it
you're getting distressed but I don't
think there's enough physical real
estate in my troll size,
arms to fit in there.
That's all I got.
We got to see him do the Scorpion poses
and shit.
He was the guy would do well I think we
found our new movement called women and
people with long arms can definitely get
their arms in better positions that
because they have more to work with.
But that also comes up in Jujitsu.
Jujitsu,
like the ability to get Darcy and oh
Jesus had.
He can do that shit.
I can't put my leg like this guy.
Look at this shit.
Just do.
Took a triangle themselves like that.
Freaky.
That's pretty cold.
Come on Bro.
That's freaky.
The guy's oldest.
Fuck.
He know why he's doing this because he's
thinking about how much dick.
He's going to swing out.
This video is dumb.
He was doing the shit when he was second
warmed up.
I'm going to fuck like this.
Let me show you.
He got up like my Dick is my legs.
I think he's still alive,
but he was doing it at 75.
He was doing.
He was on his album.
My ass.
I put Dumbo.
Triangle suck.
My Cock is not alive to.
He's never going to die at 70 6:40,
holding his weight.
He's 100 years old here.
Did his assets deteriorated beyond.
That's going.
Wow.
That's amazing.
It's 30 years old in this video.
Look at this fucking spinal flexibility
though.
That is incredible.
Don't fuck with my anger when I just say
that is incredible.
He died.
He kicked you into thinking it was no
big deal with me on cook suitcase right
there in my.
Yeah,
I can put them in a tote,
gobble,
gobble.
I can bring him in a tote and be like,
I brought my fucking gobbled from nick
my as well for extra stimulation.
Stimulation to center of Global Chinese,
Chinese just fine.
This is how I grew up with from my
backside.
Notice not a lot of spinal movement.
Just gobble.
He's talking the whole time.
Teaching.
This is what I'm thinking of coming in
my own mouth.
Maybe not today.
Today's not that impressed,
but I,
you know,
which he rarely sees though.
You really see people that are built
like Jack.
People that are really good at yoga.
There are a couple of guys I want to
know.
I want to see someone mean I know that
Hixon when he was young was pretty
fucking fit and he was on that.
Oh Ninety one,
95,
but he was way better at Yoga than most
people know.
Like hixon did.
Amazing Shit.
He used to be able to stand in a full
split on a balancing bar with his leg,
totally straight up in the air on a
bouncing Barney's.
There's videos of him dooney and Santa
Monica.
He's standing on a balancing bar with
one light,
grabs his other foot and extends it over
his fucking head while was a young
American students getting muscular.
Some of those American students like
just got shoemaker who I took a class
from.
Holy Shit.
Built like a brick dominating the yoga
game.
Now there's still a bunch of studios are
all over the place,
but I gotta think that that guy being so
crazy and all the crazy stuff that he
gets in trouble with and all the assault
allegations,
whether or not they're true,
you know,
and another thing that he did,
you know the thing,
that tax evasion thing where they found
a bunch of like a warehouse filled with
Ferrari's and beat him and he likes
Croxley's and shit.
He said that he was opening up a school
for children to teach them auto repair.
So that's why.
I mean come on Bro.
He's awesome.
He's amazing.
And he's a yoga guy,
like everything's so fucked up about it.
He's like,
he's supposed to be abused in love and
prosperity and it's important to the
spirituality.
Not your money now.
Fuck that millionaire teaching strategy.
It's great.
Yeah.
Now I think he just stays in India now.
Fucking America.
Is there anyone else killing the game
like that?
Not really,
no.
Not that I can think of.
Ray Shiva,
rea,
Max strong.
There are a lot of guys who are,
have a really great reputation who have
a lot of stuff.
Was an older lady that taught to be
grown there was pretty famous.
Danny knows her.
She went to Haiti and she's in
tremendous shape.
Oh,
isn't she the lady that runs that?
The place golden bridge or something
like that.
And La.
Yes.
She's like a coon Delaney.
Mass Kundalini is the shit that the
people who do it and even denny says,
you can have psychedelic experiences on
it that if you do it and you get into a
certain state where you do the yoga over
and over again to enough,
you can actually stimulate that part in
your brain that produces dmt.
I was trying to get a stretch,
man.
Eddie,
your friend.
The lady,
the lady that
you went to Egypt with,
didn't she wasn't she?
She knew that she was able to do that.
Right.
She would tell you she'd have
psychedelic experiences pay out.
So that's people that we had bad.
Yeah.
She had bang at four in the morning to
shake up the,
the,
the.
I don't know that maybe the dmt out
state,
but she wanted to check in the morning.
I know.
It's funny,
right?
He was into it.
Well,
but the thing is like your brain does
produce that shit and so these people
that say they know how to do it,
it's not outside the realm of
possibility.
Like it might be possible for you to
figure out a way to do it.
I've never done it,
I've only done it through the drug
itself,
but there's got to be a way to get your
brain to do it.
I had a.
well it sounds.
I didn't even have to explain it,
but I swear to God like there was a
period of time when I was practicing
taekwondo so much and I was like,
you know,
you get to a point where you practiced
enough where you can think you're kicked
out and they're going gonna laugh at
this.
Me,
you started releasing dmt is so crazy.
You say anything.
I'm gonna tell you whatever you're
saying I'm going to have a problem with.
So I'm going,
I'm going and I'm committed.
I didn't know whether it was going to
say you left off at when I used to
practice taekwondo,
but I think the way I was stretching my
body opened up something where I.
where I went.
I kicked and I,
I swear to God,
it's gonna sound weird,
but from that point on I got way neater
with the way I kept my room and the way
I kept my car and it made sense to me.
Something aligned and there was such a
drug induced,
but something happened there and then I
thought you're going to say that your
thoughts.
When many kicks that your arm,
you just punch and way harder like that
movie rookie.
I fell the tree.
I felt a tree.
A tree was in the way and I side kick
the trio.
I don't see any giant oak.
No.
Steve.
Alright.
Alright,
we'll do it.
We'll do it dry.
Fuck it.
We'll do it.
We'll do a dry dry.
Hey man,
we're going to talk about the fights
guys.
Fuck.
A lot of people fall off about Kundalini
Yoga.
Yeah,
let's watch that and then we'll go to
UFC of retirement from MMA removed from
drug testing pool.
That's what I would do too if I wanted
to take drugs.
Just saying he looks good though,
Dave.
I wanted to get super jacked again.
I'm like,
well someday someday we'll work out a
deal,
but for now I'm going to toss bitches on
their head.
I like to do that when I weigh about
3:40,
so let's get that.
Brendan and I were talking about how I
liked art for people like Anderson
Silva.
I want Anderson to take a testosterone
and whatever it takes because I want to
see the old anderson you didn't like the
Dad Bod know and I'm serious like for
me,
a great like that,
who's obviously,
you know,
getting older.
I want to see him fight at the best he
can.
I miss his incredible skillset and by
the way,
if he's,
he's got the mind,
he understands fighting on such a deep
level.
His body might just not be with
fastest.
His mind wants to.
I want a cat.
I want to catch you out because you're
supposed to end your career when your
body doesn't react to say,
look,
you can.
You can make an argument for the Vito
Belfort School of mma,
you know,
because that's what you get.
You get the old veteran with the young
body.
No.
Yeah.
I'm talking about when Bryan,
when?
When vituro rather was at the peak of
his,
like most latest cycle.
Right?
When you knocked out Luke rockhold.
When he fucked up Michael Bisping Dude,
when he knocked out Dan Henderson the
first time,
he was a goddamn force of science and
that's what he was.
He was unbelievable.
Training,
a lifetime of skill.
All that stuff is important.
First,
write a lifetime skill.
Lifetime of technique,
ridiculous,
ferocious warrior spirit,
right?
He's gonna motherfucking Vito Belfort.
Then you add synthetic testosterone and
you get a monster.
That's what you got when I'm telling you
that guy to this day,
like that period I,
I think is one of the scariest fighters
that has ever fought in the sport.
I think TRT RTV tour is one of the
fucking scariest guys that ever did,
but definitely the best one.
80 five on planet earth at the time he
was for awhile,
man.
He was terrified.
He was fearless,
destroyed rockhold.
We'll take both of them.
He thought to through to.
We'll kicks in his whole career and one
of them was he missed with Luke
rockhold.
The other one.
He hit him in the face.
We never saw that from him before.
He threw some kicks.
He threw nice,
but he was more of a boxing style
fighter and then fucked up bisping's eye
with a kick.
Yeah,
headcase.
Unbelievable.
Bisbing Simon.
Some issues before that as well.
But that definitely didn't.
No,
it didn't help.
Like Vito was a monster.
Henderson.
We get them now.
Like it's,
it's,
you know,
even with a Weidman,
which is not the same animal fight.
Kelvin.
Kelvin Gaslin in,
in Brazil.
Yeah.
What do you think about that?
Why?
Why do you think being in Brazil is a
big deal?
Um,
I can get some help to regulate his body
back to where are you saying what do
you,
when you started your body starts
producing estrogen and all that.
You can't get it back if it goes to
Brazil,
right?
They're going to go to Brazil for short.
Did you go to Brazilian?
I just won't go a lot.
It wouldn't be the other time.
And like with Josie Outta,
when they tried testing him,
they,
they made the guy like,
he,
he had to stay at customs.
They won't let him leave.
Like it was super weird.
Will tell the whole story.
The whole story.
You got this the first time they came,
he wouldn't do it.
He wouldn't take the test because he
said he didn't know the guy,
but apparently the way it happens,
so like,
you know,
I've talked to people that had been
tested that like it's super shady.
They come up to you,
they'll take you into a room that test
you.
It's not sterile.
They just like,
we want to test you right now though.
Watch you.
When you go to the bathroom.
Tim Kennedy said they had watched him
take a shower.
They'd look at him.
She's like,
you get home from training and they're
like,
we want to test you,
take a shower.
I can't take my eyes off you.
They can't.
You can't do it that way for a reason.
Because we were cheating.
You can't.
They can't.
So anyway,
so the all the guy,
they're trying to deport him to try to
kick him out of Brazil,
like the literally trying to get him out
of it.
It was time to say,
you don't have any authority to test us.
You're not even from this country.
Like they're throwing the kitchen sink
at them.
Then finally the next day they get them
to test,
right?
He gives them tests and he trips and
spills it.
Who does,
although it's fantastic.
So like what?
There you go and then.
So he has to give him another one and
then it doesn't mean anything he didn't
do.
He didn't fail.
Doesn't mean anything,
but it's all like these guys like
vandelay runs away from the guy.
They come to his gym,
but go google takes off.
Sure.
You know,
which is the.
He got fucked more than anybody ever and
the history of that.
However,
because they banned him for life,
which is insane.
It's 100 percent reversed that.
Nope.
Well they did.
They made it unconstitutional or
whatever the fuck they did.
They said it was illegal,
but they haven't reinstated them.
No.
But did you see the.
They're about to give cyborg exemption.
Well,
they see that they figured out whatever
it is that she has,
whatever personal medical issue that she
has and that this drug does help that
personal medical issue and since it's
not necessarily a performance enhancing
drug,
what it,
what it is,
is it's a diuretic.
It also is a,
it helps when women start experiencing
effects from a androgens,
like it mitigates some of the negative
effects of Androgens is that there's a
bunch of different properties that
these,
uh,
different diuretics have and whatever
her condition is,
apparently they're,
they're examining at testosterone a
therapeutic use exemption and it looks
like it's exonerates her and you know,
and all of us who said that she was
doing something she shouldn't have been
doing.
Well,
we don't know what the reasons why she
was doing it in the first place are.
But we know that in her background
though,
it's not,
it's not like crazy to assume other
things,
but that Duran to me as soon as she won.
So yeah,
everything's all good.
Like how,
how do you a Cyborg?
She's ready to go get my fucking hand
hurts down a little while.
Yeah.
Isn't that crazy time world champion,
right?
Or 46?
No,
in Moitai 10 time world champion.
He bring up Cyborg and she's like,
Jesus,
my hand,
it's like world champion if I.
You just free to sign up,
but you can't say that like right after
a fight,
like really?
I don't think she's afraid of February.
That was broken.
She said I'm going to fight with the
brother and then I'm going to fix it.
And she could go into 47 and cyborg
would knock her face off.
Do you think so?
Yes.
It's going to be interested in.
It gets not say that again.
Was going to destroy her.
Isn't she attend like a 10 time Muy Thai
champion here.
Do not care.
It doesn't matter.
But you saw it doesn't matter what you
saw with Cyborg Fart.
Georgina barge,
right?
We're going to bars.
You know,
won the fight beside board was very
brave for taking that five shots.
She did,
but that's also straight kickbox also.
Big Gloves,
right?
Yes.
Cyborg
people.
Forget how strong she is,
how good she is on the ground and the
way she hits those kicks are going to do
shit.
Enjoy.
That too.
Enemy was impressive,
but I just feel like that's you that
sure I'm 100 percent yet Brennan Shaw,
kiss her death.
The champion could do holly brown ear
cut.
Eddie Alvarez a pig problem for conor.
Say that.
Did you say cut to Congress?
Hasn't sold me yet.
Oh,
come on.
Who is the fuck?
Can you guys see the fucking conor
mayweather thing?
It's getting close.
They're saying that it's like literally
agreed upon.
Amazing.
So what do you think's going to happen?
Do you think he's going to run into an
issue with the UFC?
But do you think he's right about the
Ali Act?
I don't know,
but I think we looked at it.
I have looked at what I think's going to
happen is I think Dana,
there's no way Dan would let this happen
without being part of.
I think they come to agreement with the
UFC and Dana's part of it and it
happens.
Here's a question for you,
Joe.
Who's going to commentate it?
Boxing and UFC and boxing match.
It would be a boxing in boxing.
Yeah,
but you need someone who's knowledgeable
on conor mcgregor dedicate that.
You can't have so many boxes.
No,
it'd be way,
way better if they did it.
Then if the UFC concept.
Both you have.
I think you have to have one balls,
deep boxing expert and one mma.
Why though?
Because I know,
but kind of come from that background.
They can give you the history of cotton
and all that stuff,
but the sport is the sport is boxing,
so I feel like you could have somebody
who just brush up on that,
right?
I don't think so.
Someone who represents us,
would you not do it,
Joe?
No,
I don't want to do that.
Really?
I want to watch what you guys want to
get drunk.
That's fair.
No,
listen,
if that's happening,
we're getting hammered and we're going
to fuck with a companion,
but I'd rather do that than be there
live.
I swear to God I would.
I tell everybody I'm like,
I love compensated for the UFC,
but I fucked up when I started doing the
fight companion because the fight
companions epic.
It's so much more fun when we get fucked
up and we're laughing and how I chose
the knockout and we're watching the
second.
I'm sorry,
but it's better.
It is better.
Like being there live is fucking insane.
I mean,
I enjoyed this past weekend,
but I would have definitely enjoyed it
more if you guys were there.
Yeah,
that's the.
Yes,
you should do.
We should make some sort of a deal where
we do it like this.
Do Colic.
Let those other guys take over the
commentary and we'll just have this like
we'll have like to sound things you can
choose.
You can choose to be companion.
He just go from having an interpreter.
Listen man,
it's.
You get to see people who don't even
need a component and have fun.
Your companion button you just think is
annoying.
Sinkings annoying.
Yes,
we should do that.
Should be like the Spanish channel or
the span.
You know,
it should be like a little button.
You press and option like you get closed
captions.
You know how you get closed captions.
Fight.
Watch the.
You just put it on mute and like what
everyone else does on mute.
I want to hear the slap of the kicks.
I want to hear dudes move around.
I want to hear it.
I want to be in here.
See what we're missing.
What we're missing is not that there's
anything wrong with the commentary,
the commentary is great,
but we can't really broadcast that
Kombucha because it's not our product.
Right.
But if we were sitting here,
we were watching it and we had a raw
feed where there was no commentary,
just slaps and punches and kicks and you
know,
and we would also like have our own take
on what the fuck is happening rather
than the commentators take and you know,
if we're wrong,
it'd be even more hilarious because for
drunk stoned dudes talking shit while
they're making each other like mystery
science theater that they offered you a
deal.
But they said no weed,
you can smoke weed.
He would say,
okay,
that doesn't make any sense.
It's legal.
Like marijuana is legal in California.
We're adults.
We pay taxes for just for weed itself.
I'd have to stand up for weed.
You know,
that's like if somebody said you could
do your stand up,
but you can't swear,
I be like,
because of who?
Like it's not hurting anybody if I swear
it's not hurting anybody.
If I smoke weed.
No,
I'm not gonna agree to that.
That's stupid because I'm in a position
where I don't have to agree to stupid
shit.
That's a stupid thing to agree to.
Imagine you're working with someone.
You're working with someone that I
really like you,
Brian,
but I don't want.
You only were in yellow.
Okay,
you can work with me,
but only wear yellow.
Do you understand?
Yellow is our color.
It's how we want to be represented.
When we're giving you the ones and
Zeros,
we want you to dress with appropriate
colors.
That is so stupid.
I can't smoke weed.
Fuck you.
What do you want?
A shitty show.
Exactly.
What do you want to have less?
Real sponsor gets companies sponsored by
certain wines.
Chateaus bypass on that call for Eddie
call.
Yes.
Yeah.
We don't necessarily need alcohol all
the time,
but every now and then we go off the
rails and the bad for the main event
shots,
color shots about.
Well,
we're going to have to do is on the next
studio.
I'm going to have a button where we have
a.
we're talking over each other button,
so like a button.
I could press were enough to say it,
but we'll see like flames all around us.
Oh,
it's going bad.
Like I like video were there were there
were there.
Just to let us know.
Everyone has a button.
When they're talking,
they hold a button or dentist radios,
walkie talkie,
electric shock live.
There's A.
There's a.
there's a light.
You can't get talked over.
They do have these things,
these arms that we have that have a
light on it.
When that I didn't think was,
look,
they look good,
but now I decided you want.
I'm a Dork.
I want a little light on these things
that light up.
We're on the Internet.
Makes us.
Is it a green light?
No,
it's red Bro.
Will that be something like the one on
the air,
like Brian said,
fire,
Bro.
I see you.
Ryan.
Seacrest has one though.
Fuck.
He wasn't makeup before.
He does radio.
Was everything.
Everything.
Do you think his shirt was rips in it?
I thought that Puma p 45
that killed those out pacas I spent.
I spent two fucking weeks for that guy.
Did you fuck them?
Did you get to small guys about 1:40?
Maybe.
I enjoy the taste.
I don't know what you talking about.
We got drunk and his study we were
reading was he told me,
was he like a guy's guy or were you guys
like Jack and he's a nice guy.
I didn't really friendly guy.
I've done a show before.
I said something to the effect of did
well this year.
He made $30,000,000
that year.
I go,
what?
Well,
he goes having a lot of fun,
having a lot of fun.
He's like a.
He produced it.
Who produced the Kardashians?
She's involved with all that.
He's getting paid.
He's originally from Finland or
somewhere.
He said he's like originally not
American fucking foreigners.
I think stealing all our fucking factory
jobs for president.
I think he's Swedish.
He is from somewhere else.
Drama.
I'm wrong.
He's killing the game though.
American idol.
There's two hosts and the one guy was
like,
fuck it.
This isn't going into Jordan's secret.
Stayed with it.
And so he's from Georgia.
So Brian just made that Swedish.
What would you say?
You're completely full of shit.
Just sweet and then Jordan,
he's from little little Sweden and
George.
Jennifer Lopez still on one of those
shows.
American idol's a Jennifer Lopez.
The America.
No,
I think they're bringing it back,
but it's been off for a couple of
seasons.
Oh,
Jennifer Lopez is doing that show with
Steve Sharp on that show.
That's the photos.
Did you see?
Jay Loves J.
Lo at the grammy's.
God damn she is fine.
She,
she,
she gets better and better and she's
older than that.
I think she's 59 or late forties.
God,
she and rose McGowan and my two
favorites.
As far as physical delivery,
physical,
those two.
It seems weird that you know.
No,
no.
Rose McGowan is on a basic white girl
face sheet.
Let me say I did something with her back
in the day.
I did this thing for vh one where I
played a perverted fashion photographer
that was just in it to get laid.
And I had a couple scenes with her.
She's cool as fuck.
And she's,
uh,
she's very pretty like,
like her face Manson was taken that we
did this thing.
It was 1996.
I think it was somewhere around
[inaudible] 97.
We're talking about the girl from the
notebook.
No.
Think of Rachel rose McGowan.
That's my ass.
Oh my God.
You got these big hanging out the front.
My Dick was showing.
Yeah,
the idea was gorgeous.
This is rose McGowan.
Oh,
I said to this girl,
do you have any problems with nudity?
That's rose McGowan.
Oh,
you got to see her in real life.
Too sick.
She's.
She's beautiful man.
Bad shot.
Look at Brian.
Brian.
Brian,
look.
Oh my God.
Damn.
You had your Dick hanging out the front
of it.
Yeah,
I did.
I had to show her my deck because the
idea was I had to say,
do you have any problems with nudity?
And she said,
no,
cut to me naked.
Taking a picture.
There was major as being a crazy person
that was like really into a with
photography.
That's hilarious.
I was just trying to get laid.
I didn't know anything about
photography.
That was like the Joe Gibbs is made by a
friend of mine who was one of the
writers on the radio.
It's how's Paul says?
Do you ever keep in touch with them?
I run into him or talk to them very
rarely,
but up to last time I talked to him was
when Phil Hartman got a star on the
Hollywood walk of fame.
We went down there to be there for it
and it was like a whole celebration with
a bunch of,
uh,
Phil Hartman fans.
Paul was working on a bunch of different
shows.
He's always working on different things,
you know,
I think he did boardwalk empire for a
while.
Did that show so good.
So awesome.
So smart man.
And he's one of the most unusually
talented people I've ever met.
He's an incredible vital,
hilarious,
but she's super smart.
That landed in borderline.
Who's fuck news radio?
Do you ever see news radio?
The show?
He used to be on one of the greatest
sitcoms ever.
Dude,
he was the coolest guy ever to work for
if you ran a show because he didn't give
a fuck if you came up with a funnier
line like when,
when he moved here,
right?
None,
zero.
The whole writing crew was just about
get the best line out there.
So like Dave Foley was constantly
rewriting shit constantly.
We would write jokes for each other,
like we would see something and you
know,
and Vicky Lewis would say to Andy,
how about you try this?
She was amazing.
It was great to candy Alexander.
Amazing.
And it was,
it was a crazy cast,
like super,
super,
super talented.
It was amazing,
man.
He will kill you with the shit he would
do.
But I had to do many scenes with them.
And you did an episode with them?
Yeah,
you can't,
like it's hard to like keep a straight
face.
Like if I was supposed to be pissed,
like I'd be like,
I'd be like Andy,
what happened?
And,
and,
and he would say something.
He would go and you'd be like biting
your face,
their face to keep from.
I would slap myself in the face in
between.
Takes to try to get like I didn't laugh.
He's so funny and unpredictable.
Like he's so talented.
Like I did less than perfect within too.
Yeah.
He would just come out and do shit.
And you'd be like,
what's he gonna do now?
And he was always fucking hilarious and
there was Stephen Root,
who's like one of the best actors I've
ever met him.
This other person,
he was like this.
He would do a scene,
he would just become someone else.
He just wasn't there anymore.
Like he would be Jimmy James,
like he would get out of the realm,
you'd be Stephen Root,
you'd be hanging out with them.
He's like this normal guy.
And then he'd come on the set with a
suit on as Jimmy James and he's Jimmy
James was raised.
He was weird.
He was a real actor.
That guy's been acting forever,
like highly trained,
skilled.
Like he was the only one in the cast
that had like a real character.
Yes.
I mean Phil was just an exaggerated
fill,
but his character like had a different
way of talking or different mannerism.
Like he had all planned that out.
[inaudible].
It's an amazing,
amazing show.
Chemistry like that is very rare.
It's just creates gold.
It's really don't know how we got to
that.
But that dude didn't give a fuck.
He's like all about the best line,
whatever the best line is,
whoever's coming up with the best line.
Yeah,
but when you work in an like that,
then it makes it fun.
When you work with like someone's just
super restrictive and like,
you know,
like they don't let you just express
yourself.
Then you know those sitcoms or two
stores.
You've been in those environments too.
Fucking hard to do.
Man.
This is so easy to do.
A podcast is the easiest form of show
business of all time.
It really is.
It is.
And like for doing shit,
it's the best form trays.
It,
it's like the least managed.
It's still the least prepared.
But like if you're listening,
if you like,
if I'm doing something like around my
house,
like if I'm cleaning my office or
something like that,
I want to listen to a podcast I listen
to when I work out.
Now you stolen listening to music that I
listened,
a pug Jesus that we might be balls deep
too deep in the world to do so much to
learn game.
It's all at your fingertips.
You don't have enough time in the day to
learn shit on the planet,
talk like you can go to Sam Harris and
listed the smartest motherfuckers on the
planet,
have listened to people super stupid to
make yourself feel better and I'll
listen to them.
You think this is doing something to the
way people communicate.
I do think.
I do think that the world is becoming
less a brutal and ignorant in many ways.
For example,
you'd find in we went back even a
hundred years,
but let's say a hundred and 30 years you
would find a large portion of the globe
that could have a conversation with you
on why slavery is necessary and can be a
virtuous in certain circumstances for
certain people and you'd have no problem
finding maybe half the globe who would
have a serious conversation with you
justifying a form of slavery in today.
In 2017,
you would be hard pressed to find anyone
who could morally or ethically justify
the idea that you should own a slave and
a North America now in the world also
economically not viable anymore.
See,
like if you could do something like
Foxconn and have a bunch of people
stocked up inside some place and feed
them and house them and they work 16
hours a day and jump off the building so
much.
You have to put nets around.
Yeah.
What is the difference?
The only difference is they can leave.
They can leave if they want to,
but at some weird kind of form of of
slaves and indentured servitude or
whatever it is,
depending on the economy.
What I'm saying is that you.
You would have,
for example,
if you.
The minute you said,
I know exactly what you're saying,
I know exactly what you're saying.
That's progress to an extent where the
con was to accept.
Yeah,
but isn't it bizarre?
I mean like what we're talking about
that like you get something from Japan
or China rather and you know that it
came from one of those kinds of
factories and you're okay with it.
I mean we're all okay with it.
We have to be.
If you want a new iphone,
right?
Well if you want any phone android,
the android Samsung.
I don't know how.
I don't know,
I'm okay when I don't know.
I'm okay with it for the following
reason.
We went through our own industrial
revolution and the fact of the matter is
that when economies are growing and can
throw a lot of examples
of that,
look at Korea 30 years ago,
look at China 20 years ago,
look at all these countries who have,
who have gained great prosperity and
higher standards of living for massive
sections of their population.
They all started that way.
They all started,
you know,
it's very difficult to grow your country
to become an industrial powerhouse.
No,
I totally understand that Brian.
But it's just weird that we allow people
to pay people,
like essentially it's not a company in
China or you know,
it's kind of an American company and a
lot of ways of slavery.
Slavery.
Exactly.
Way Cheaper to,
to,
to have like an involuntary slavery
network than it is a va because if you
make it involved,
like,
you know,
instead of forced slavery,
um,
you're paying them so little that they
can never leave.
You just basically,
instead of providing food for them,
you're just basically giving them the
money that you would spend.
If it was real slavery,
yeah,
you'd have to buy their food and Shit
and then you'd have to have guards and
you have to pay guards and now the
security will feed them there too.
I mean,
it's real creepy.
It's you got to realize that like even
whoever owns the company,
whether it's Chinese people,
the American people,
the American companies have these big
deals with them for a reason because
they can take advantage of those
loopholes because they.
Their manufacturing tolerances are super
high.
They really know how to do it.
There are,
there is a lot of pressure from
responsible corporate American companies
and they go into those.
Those they go in there because they're
shareholders find out about this stuff
and they go in there and by the way
there I would imagine that a lot of
people that work at apple is going to
sound really surprising and these other
companies are pretty ethical and moral
and don't and I've very familiar with
not feeling good about the fact that
their company might have a relationship
with a Chinese affiliate who doesn't
treat their workers well and in fact a
lot of these corporations like apple
were very,
very.
An Ibm for example,
were instrumental in going in there and
saying,
hold it.
We're not doing business this way.
You're environmental practices.
I mean there was a whole article about
how ibm,
if you do business with ibm,
good luck because your vendors,
your vendors better be environmentally
responsible.
Ibm has these environmental standards
that are just draconian almost for a lot
of companies where it's like,
you may be environmentally responsible
and you work for us.
We're a big client for you,
but how about the people that work for
you?
How's that draconian though?
Well,
it's not draconian.
I'm saying that that a lot of these
corporations have to be responsible to
share.
Yeah,
smart,
and they go,
I don't want to do business where people
are indentured.
Definitely right to say that,
but it's also 100 percent,
but hold on.
It's still,
no matter what you just said that made
it look cute.
There's still 100 percent fact those
people make almost nothing and that's
how you get your laptop made.
I mean if you want to break it down to
reality,
the only way you can say whatever you
want,
but it's the only widget that is is is
it possible that this can turn back
around and they can start meeting.
The idea of American manufacturing is
thing.
Things that have been kicked around back
and forth since this whole campaign got
started essentially,
right.
Was a big part of what trump getting
into office was bringing back American
manufacture.
Great.
Again,
we all know the story of Detroit.
We have all seen like how they're.
Oh,
there's another fucking documentary that
they're doing about this guy who was
building a farm in Detroit,
the largest farm.
They're making a huge farm in the middle
of Detroit.
They're like knocking down all these
buildings,
buying up all this land,
and they're just going to build an urban
farm or what were you going to ask
though?
What was the question about the realist
out to bring manufacturing jobs back?
Yeah.
I mean doing the idea of it,
the idea of like reigniting the
manufacturing base of the United States
and having everything being American
made being a big thing,
but here's some stuff like electronics
and things like that.
Is it even past.
So here's the problem is first of all,
the reason that we don't pay crazy
amounts of reason that the consumers get
to pay not a lot of money for a flat
screen tv or whatever it might be.
The reason crisis seemed to come down.
You can go to Walmart and buy a lot of
shit for not as much money.
There's efficiency,
there's a price for efficiency of
course,
but for the most part,
if you go to the.
If you look at the infrastructure that
over 20 years China has built with those
factories that are so incredibly
efficient and clean and and have just
locked into exactly how to churn out as
much product and your company and your
bottom line is you're responsible.
For example,
if you're a public court mandate,
you're responsible to your shareholders
to make them as much money,
as many dividends as you can,
and on top of that turn of profit,
you're going to make your product for as
little money as possible.
And by the way,
it's also gonna allow you to bring the
price down to your consumers can buy.
So what I'm saying,
what I'm saying is that we all know that
infrastructure without infrastructure.
I have good luck with the American
manufacturing sector trying to compete
with the Chinese who have a 20 year head
start and I and I,
I think that's a fantasy.
Not only is bringing manufacturing jobs
back to the US as a fantasy,
but more importantly,
we're not even using human beings with
real enemy to unemployment is our
automation is not just a 100 million
Chinese workers that showed up over the
past 20 years.
Fox automation,
Foxconn,
CEO says investment for display plant in
us would exceed $7,000,000,000,
a lot of money,
so they have these plants that are
already set up in China.
Very high standards for tolerances for
their manufacturing,
for not just this,
but also for clothes.
All sorts of things.
I made.
We just had a meeting with this company
and they were saying how they went to
American factory because they're looking
out source,
choose tee shirts,
all this stuff,
and then went to American factory and
then they went to the in China and goes,
it's China's like the Bentley or royals
Royce have factories in the one that
went to America that produces a lot of
our American shit.
He said it was awful like there.
They wouldn't put up with it.
The standards are even close.
You wouldn't do the people that are
jumping out of buildings.
Is that a clean place or dirty places?
It's
clean,
clean belting,
Eddie.
I mean,
I know it seems like a fantasy,
but doesn't it sound like we should.
We should.
We should try.
We ever happened.
It'll never happen to.
We are trying to fuck China.
Let's bring the jobs back here.
We got to at least try at least give
trump a shot.
We'll see.
We are trying,
but even trump realizes and everybody
realizes that there are some companies
that countries that do things more
efficiently.
Right?
So for example,
just as a bad example,
bananas are easier to grow in the
Dominican Republic than they would
because of the climate and all that.
Then they would be in Detroit,
right?
Just because of the weather and stuff.
So that's kind of the idea behind the
global economy.
The idea that certain companies do it
eat certain countries,
have the infrastructure,
have the cheaper labor and it's easier
to churn out more product,
thereby keep.
But You keep saying cheaper labor,
like it's no big deal.
I'm not saying it's no big deal.
It just talk about slave labor,
this whole country's wealth here.
How do you defend?
It?
Raises the standard of living sorta.
Yeah,
but starts it.
Not sort of Brian,
settle the fuck down.
It does,
but it does in a way where you're doing
it off the back of the people that are
making $5 a week course.
Okay,
but that's what we keep saying and you
keep glossing over.
It went up when I'm trying to explain
like why it's a problem to a lot of
people that listen to this.
You want to gloss over it and Fox News
it up,
sir.
I don't listen to Fox News by the way.
Let's get a couple things straight.
The fuckers get them.
I don't get my news off a CNN or Fox
News gets.
Who doesn't read news?
It's all.
Who's your fuckers?
Where do you get your news?
I read.
I read publications and I do a lot of
blow shit.
I do a lot of bluff.
I'm not glossing over anything.
I'm trying to say,
is this really something that you keep
saying it?
We know what I'm saying is definitely
less than a standard.
If you go over one more time,
I'm going to freak Brian.
You're being very repetitive.
Standard of living in those countries
has raised exponentially said that of
these people that are making things,
not of buildings.
Brian,
we got to Brian.
it's illegal to make those people work
like that in the United States for a
fucking reason,
and they're human beings,
so if they're human beings and China and
they're working in this horrendous
conditions are not insane hours.
They are Brian and some aren't.
They're living these factory.
Some factories.
You're 100 percent right.
I would know there was some factories.
It's just a disco.
They go in,
they give them a drink.
Everybody gets a foot massage work
there.
I'm not saying I got to not saying that
Fox News Dad is coming out of your mouth
as I have nothing against slavery.
No,
I'm not saying that.
I believe in slave labor.
It's not hard work.
I'm just saying that every country has
industrialized the same way.
That's.
They were a bunch of.
The factory was filled with a bunch of
hot women from Norway that were sweaty
all the time of the breasts are hanging
out.
We've been fucking trying to save them.
We can't make them work these hours.
I just can't do it,
but because it's Chinese people,
Brian's legacy economies,
the Chinese,
the Chinese demanding higher wages to do
an export in their jobs to other
countries of the week.
They can buy a subway sandwich.
Footlong maybe off.
Maybe I am not saying you end of the
week.
Those characteristics.
You're mischaracterizing little plastic
cup and get some water.
How much would an iphone costs if we
built it in the thousand dollars?
Million Dollars.
$1,000,000.
What do you think?
They're like 700 bucks an hour.
First of all,
we literally don't have the kind of
factory,
so you'd have to build the factory.
You'd have to build this month,
so it costs billions of dollars to build
one of those super high tech factories
too much more.
Then on top of that,
you would have to hire people as he
falls asleep.
That's substantial wage,
but it could be done.
It's not an impossible thing.
It was done in China.
It could be done over here.
They can make it will cost more.
It would definitely cause you would go
up,
but don't you think that the country
should subsidize fucking iphones instead
of corn?
Because all these cuts are putting corn
and everything and Corn Syrup and this
and that.
Everybody's getting fat as fuck and
people are dying of heart attacks.
Just got goddamn corn port.
Hey,
protein.
Hey by the corn powder.
Can I just talk for a second?
That'd be okay.
All this corn and everything.
Jesus Christ,
maybe we subsidized cell phone talking
to a lot more.
They need fucking corn.
Talk to Archer Daniels Midland lobbying
efforts strong about slaves and how good
they are.
So Slavery Motherfucker,
right?
It's a free country.
I can say what I want,
but you know those,
the guys that own these factories in
China,
you know,
they're down to like,
they want to assassinate trump.
Right?
Thanks.
So he's really gonna.
Pull those,
those.
Uh,
they don't.
None of them not threatened at all.
It took so long to do that.
A loop.
No one's gonna know Eddie.
No one's going to do it.
Then.
Let's look.
First of all,
you hear what he was talking about,
like putting the taxes on Mexico to
build the wall and stuff like that.
All those proposals have to get through
congress.
Yeah,
and good luck.
Good luck with all that and especially
because he doesn't see.
The thing about running a country is
it's very different than running a
business.
There's a bunch of checks and balances.
If he's running a business,
he's the king.
Like there was this thing that John
Oliver had on a show,
but we were talking about how like he
would exaggerate about the amount of
floors in this building.
You know,
you think you're on the 14th floor,
but really on the eighth floor because
he would like say there's like 68
floors,
58.
He just does whatever he wants,
but it makes it look more exciting.
But you can't,
when you're dealing with Congress,
that's not going to work because when
you run,
if you run it like that,
see the reason why it's good that
there's this brock,
your seat in place,
bureaucracy in place is that if someone
isn't with the right or the left or on
their own and they want to run this
thing,
like I'm gonna bring my own security,
I'm gonna.
Run out,
nobody's gonna be on your side like.
And those people have to be on your
side.
So then you have to figure out how
you're gonna work with these people to
get things on your side.
But you have to do it legally and you're
being watched for the microscope.
Everybody's looking at everything you
do.
That's why this guy,
what is he,
what's his name?
Flint that got.
He got removed today.
I stepped down.
He had to step down in a business.
What he did would have been mum,
mum under the table.
Everybody shut the fuck up.
They're doing deals.
So talking to people to try the
Russians.
Mischaracterize what you said.
What did he do?
We should look it up very specifically,
but from what I understand is he had an
inappropriate conversation with Russian
emissaries about sanctions.
Whether or not those sanctions would be
wet,
you know,
eased up under the because we have
sanctions on Russia because he's a poor
fit for national security advisor.
Michael Flynn resigned and then scroll
down a little bit there.
It says,
National Security Advisor,
Michael Flynn,
has resigned after reports that he
misled senior White House officials
about his conversations with Russia.
The liberals are freaking out right now
screaming into their lockers.
Conservatives are,
I know president trump has named,
but the liberals are fucking.
They're ready to ride like shit on fire.
It's going to go down to starbucks,
kicked the door in retired army,
Lieutenant General Keith Kellogg as
Acting National Security Advisor.
Kellogg previously served as Flynn's
chief of staff,
blah,
blah blah,
blah.
The embattled Flynn blamed his
resignation late Monday on the fast pace
of events that led him to inadvertently
give vice president pence and others
incomplete information in quote about
his phone conversations with Russia's
ambassador to the U.
S Sergei Kissy Celiac.
They probably recorded those
conversations and if he said anything
about sanctions being eased up when
trump comes into power,
etc.
That would be very unapplied guy.
I have sincerely,
sincerely apologize To the president,
the vice president,
and they have accepted my apology for
flynn wrote in his resignation letter.
Wow.
This is weird.
Really weird.
Look at this.
Pencil defended flynn's contact with
Russia and when it became clear,
the national security advisor had not
been forthcoming.
Series questions raised about his
ability to keep the job.
This is fucking house of cards,
like house of cards is real,
especially since Russia,
according to both sides of the aisle,
was probably involved in hacking.
Don't say that you keep saying hacking
because they didn't do anything that
actually affected the election.
They might have done something in
affected people's perceptions and let it
affected the way they votes but the
thumb.
But what they did was never disputed.
Like when the information they pulled
up,
no one's ever saying it's fake.
They're saying it's true.
So what they did,
where they showed that hillary was
rigging the primaries against bernie
sanders,
the say that that influenced the
election.
Yes it did,
but it influenced it because what they
did was dirty as fuck and business as
usual and then people got a chance to
look at it.
Well,
they also know that that russian agents
are.
It's alleged russian agents hacked into
certain dnc computers.
So just high level high level democrats.
That's all well think there is proof,
but the bottom line is even if they did
do it,
what they released is something that we
should know about because we should know
the democratic party is against one of
the most popular people of the
democratic party.
There just wasn't playIng ball.
That's bernie sanders,
bernie sanders,
a guy who's legitimately altruistic like
seems like.
It seems like a guy was legitimately not
controlled by money.
Seems like a guy who is legitimately
looking maybe even misguided by some
economics though.
economist standards,
maybe even misguided,
but the idea that he's trying to change
the income inequality in this country in
some way,
shape or form,
at the very least,
he's opening up the dialogue about it
and the Helen Hayes and all the other
people are hitting the brakes on that
shit and we found out about it,
so we found out about the crazy
bureaucracy.
We found out about hillary talking about
marijuana and saying that she's against
it in every sense of the word.
Marijuana legalization.
She's helping people who are spending
money because they're going to make
money if pod is illegal,
so she's essentially making it okay for
cops,
for jackbooted thugs to lock people up
in a fucking cage over pi.
You're saying she's not just corrupt.
That's a monster.
A person who would say that she's
against marijuana legalization in every
sense of the word.
that person is an enemy of history.
Like you're a selfish monster who's
willing to do something completely
irrational just for personal gain.
That's it.
That's a knock on hillary from day one
and there are.
There's a whole paper trail though,
is so scare of hair corruption and
people don't think it's scary because
it's pot and pot sounds silly,
but it's not about pot.
It's about freedom.
It's about you doing something that
doesn't hurt anybody else in somewhat
deciding that they can lock you in a
cage because they write some things down
on paper and it's no different if she
wants to do that,
then if someone in this room wants a
lot,
one of us up for the five of us got
together and one of us wanted to lock us
up because one of us is smoking pot.
It's that fucking stupid.
It's really that stupid.
It's an insane,
insane law and the fact that she was
totally down to keep that log going in
every sense of the word.
That's an insane person.
Yeah.
Well,
it's not just that her clinton
foundation was a pay per flight.
Look up what's gone now,
right?
Isn't it?
What a surprise that it folded up.
How [inaudible] amazing that she no
longer has any influence in government
and all of a sudden the all those
donations of folded up.
What a surprise that that was an
altruistic organization,
but now that they can't grant anybody
favors,
all you have to do,
don't look this up now,
but if you're listening uranium one,
deal a whitewater and travelgate,
just those ones and look up how corrupt,
and this is why a lot of people have a
problem with the ideologues on the left,
could they won't acknowledge that,
so everybody that sees that and sees the
deep,
just integrated corruption that it's
just almost inoperable.
Corruptions,
right?
They see that and they don't want to
admit it because they say trump is bad
and if you had,
if you talk about it,
they said trump is bad and they have
valid concerns about trump,
but that doesn't negate all the problems
with her place tries elective because
the democrats decided to nominate
somebody
who in 2008,
the democratic voters already told you
they didn't like.
They didn't trust women,
didn't trust her,
not just men.
Women didn't trust her.
So at the end of the day,
you guys,
you know,
the democrats put up a candidate that
people didn't trust.
They just didn't.
She just had a history oF tufts.
She talked anytime.
Award came out of her mouth.
I didn't believe anything.
She's just the most insincere bad actors
out there.
Her husband,
he was mad.
He was believable.
You wanted to believe bill clinton,
but he was.
He was just better at line,
but she's terrible at line,
right it.
She's terrible.
Do you believe in talking you about it
is?
It's hard to imagine that the system is
so fucked up that it's missing key
players so badly that someone that
flawed could get to a position where the
country has to choose whether or not
this insanely flawed person gets to run
the country like that's crazy
intelligent.
Many people vicious and our chat and all
these smart people,
they are so.
Exactly,
and that's the problem and rightly so.
Why would you want that shitty job?
Because I'm pro slavery.
You can't do what you used to be able to
do with that job.
That job was a good job when you were
jfk.
It's not a good job When you're fucking
obama.
It's not a good job.
Stressfulness,
you're,
you're dying out there.
See obama just having the time of his
life,
no party fucking much week to week,
nonstop edibles and thinks about drones.
Didn'T he stopped smoking in the middle
of his presidency?
No.
Before I thought,
I'll ask you again.
Do you think eats edibles and thinks
about drones?
I've to my president.
I'm not going to answer that question.
It's not your friend anymore.
Yes.
I don't know.
Donald tRump's our president.
It's true.
No.
Just see that girl got tattooed on her
on her side.
I put it up on my instagram.
She's got it tattooed on her side.
Trump is not my fucking president.
Yes,
I live in America.
Bit.
That's your president,
but hoW deep is that?
Imagine going down on her.
He pulled her shirt off and you're like
a democracy vibrant.
Saying that trump is not my fucking
president.
Tattoo on someone's side makes our
democracy vibrant because that's not
correct.
Freedom of speech there,
but the writing down on your body
forever.
It's crazy because in four years they'd
be Like,
yeah.
My last last night during while Donald
Trump was running for the republican
nomination,
I really didn't pay that much attention
to.
I hear,
I heard crazy shit that he said about
mexicans.
He said this and that,
and I'm like,
damn,
he sounds like a crazy.
Didn't really pay attention.
But when,
uh,
you know,
he won the nomination,
he was going against hillary.
I started to Pay attention,
but then you always hear about shitty
set in the past.
Although I never heard it.
I just bought when he was running
against hillary and they were debating,
I agreed with to me just seemed like an
honest shit talker.
That's what it seemed like on honest
shit.
Talker,
you know,
he's not politically correct.
He said some abrasive shit,
but he's being an honest and hillary
wasn't being honest at all.
So last night I went back and I said,
you know what?
People keep saying all this shit that
donald trump's that I go,
let me,
I want to youtube.
Sorry.
The library was closed,
but I went to youtube and I punched him.
Donald trump's worst quotes and like
the,
the worst number other than I smoked,
smoked a bowl and I'm like,
let me,
let me fucking find out what the fuck he
saying and he's,
he,
he talks shit.
But I agreed with most.
I didn't really think anything was bad.
I was like,
is this a pro Donald Trump oF video?
like,
because people always hear that he said
like the worst shit.
Like he's saying shit about mexicans.
What is he saying is to calling them
wetbacks and what does he saying?
They exaggerate everything and I think a
lot of now and I'm like,
wait a minute.
I went back and I swear to god I had a
check because I was just going through
video after,
is it pro trump or against trump?
This worship to me sounds like a,
like a boss,
you know,
he's a talker.
He's up in the guide.
Then I went back and watched the ct was
saying while he was running against ted
cruz and rubio.
Those guys seem like they seem like
they'Re hypnotized.
They're like mk ultra know what they're
going to say.
Yeah.
I never had a problem with trump of what
he said,
my product that's robberies,
that he doesn't totally real.
Yeah.
I.
My worry about trump is that he's.
I think he's very,
very narcissistic,
but I also think he doesn't seem that
informed or that interested in knowing
what he doesn't know.
That was always my way.
Surround yourself with.
I don't know,
it could be a double cross.
I'm not sold on trump,
but the one thing is,
thank god it's not drunk.
All the payments in the past and I
haven't seen you do that in a long time.
I've been here for awhile.
I had to get here from meeting an hour
early,
so I've been drinking my hit my wall.
I was just happy that hillary didn't
win.
You know?
That could have been anybody on the
other side.
I just all the shit on hillary and her
camp,
the people that run her shit,
that's too dark for me.
I don't want that to keep going.
The thing.
So she could have been running against
bozo the clown.
I would have been bozos.
Bozo,
bozo or deez nuts.
What a lot of people did just to just
two things that are good about having
someone like trump in order in,
in office.
One thing is that people are going to
get energized.
Now they realize that voting works and
there's real consequences to not voting
and the person that you maybe didn't
want,
and then also we have to reexamine our
electoral college system that was
created back when people couldn't
fucking communicate with the
representatives.
You couldn't get to Washington.
Can you just vote on your email or your
computer?
There are 100 percent.
Should be a way that you vote online
just like you can just email,
email.
That's your email because you have a
social security number.
Everybody has one.
That's what you should be able to enter
to enter into an app that everybody
gets.
You have a photo,
you stand there.
It takes a photo of you,
takes your fingerprint like it does when
you order something with apple pay or
some shit and vote.
It's not hard.
It's not hard to do.
They can do it.
They just don't want to invest anytime
and they can control.
it's way easier to control controlled
groups of people.
AS soon as you have everybody that's
over 18 having access to vote
instantaneously,
their phone,
you're gonna get a different result and
you're going to get people like justin
bieber becoming president,
like really like you don't understand
like we have a popularity contest.
That's what.
That's what being the president.
It's fucking ridiculous.
If you look at the amount of people that
are on instagram or on twitter,
like people that have like 49 million
followers at any given time,
one of those motherfuckers can string
together some really good sentences and
we're like,
george clooney for president will
fucking do it.
We don't even care if you're good at it.
Katy perry,
we'd be so powerful and so amazing.
I know she can do it.
Lady gaga could be the fucking president
of the United States.
Mark my words.
She was on the superbowl.
She said she was $100 million.
Okay.
Selena gomez can be president.
I'll vote for right now.
I don't even know who she is.
She's dating the weekend.
I'm so lost.
I'm so out of the former.
Next.
The problem you can solve with the
electoral college is that if you do it
just by popular vote like that,
then that's one issue with it,
but also the fact that states that are
not very populated would get ignored by
their,
by the government because they don't get
ignored when it comes.
Yeah.
It would do when it comes ignored when
it comes to passing bills that help
them.
We're getting funding or subsidies,
but also maybe they'd have to stop god
fucking card and putting it in
everything and get with the times that
he's dying from corn.
Brian,
there's hope that corn fed on hillary.
I like that.
Oh yeah.
I never liked the spark that was.
I was under the impression that pro
libertarian brother,
um,
I'm a pretty conservative guy,
but there was no,
there was no good choices.
No,
I couldn't pick what he wants to do it.
I'm down to give trump a chance to turn
the economy around.
No,
he might after.
There's a lot of programs going to go
after them,
but I'm not sold on trump,
but I liked what he said.
I like that he's honest.
He's definitely,
he never said he never called mexicans
wetbacks or anything like that.
He just said the same shit clinton said
about immigration in more of a abrasive
way.
That's all.
He was more abrasive about it.
Well,
it bill clinton,
she said all the same shit that people
are upset sucked in the lighthouse.
That's not a big deal and it's not a big
deal.
Whoa.
I said,
let him go.
I'm a.
I'm a political.
Jfk.
Jfk had an affair with Marilyn Monroe
was married.
He had an 11 affairs during.
That could be bullshit.
That could be disciplined.
Oh,
well here's my question.
Here's my question though.
Get chlamydia.
Should Donald Trump say anything
positive happens from this?
It's going to be.
It's going to inspire other people that
are like unconventional type candidates
to run that might be better or more
likely to time.
Trump.
trump.
Trump thinks the economy is doing well.
He'll get another shot.
You know,
it's not like.
You know what?
You know.
What I like about trump is the cia is so
against him.
like john dot brennan,
the director,
he's the director of the cia.
He's against him.
Then it's a good thing for brian to list
some good about trump.
The fat guys against peo,
I believe.
What happened with this fella that used
to be head of the cia is appointed by
the president.
It's a sibling.
Sibley and appoint appointment.
Ujamaa brendan.
Right now you're usually a civilian who
runs the cia and you're appointed by
the,
by.
The lady says John O'brien.
John will brennan's the director,
right?
It's a pump peo,
isn't it?
Looked at was he was obama's director
director.
And he doesn't like the president.
Obama didn't like the problem.
Luckily you can punch that up,
put it into trump.
Trump appoints the head of the cia.
So he has his boy decided to.
If he does,
he does.
He just read it and said it and halpern
hood.
The deputy director was,
uh,
under investigation for running black
sites.
So,
you know,
if you wanT to talk about a
controversial under secretary again,
halpern is if valerie harper and she is,
she was not operative who ran a lot of
the extraordinary rendition sites.
The black sites where a detainees under
american supervision were tortured.
She ran that,
she was there.
She,
she was brought up with the senate arms,
the intelligence committee,
and questioned.
What do you think it's like to bang a
chick who runs a torture operation?
We better go hard and tried to look for
pictures.
I couldn't find pictures of hard in the
fucking pardon the paint.
Go hard in the paint chips.
He's a controversial character man,
but I'm not into dope.
I don't scratch me.
Nobody.
I'm not going to choke you out.
I can't shake.
I don't like this.
50 shades of grey has got people
confused as fuck.
Shades of brent's from working in a
fucking office.
That's what dutch shit's from.
Correct.
Being suppressed.
Work in the cubicle.
Constantly worried about human
resources.
You get out of there.
He wants a bitch to tie you up and shit
in your mouth.
Dry data to dominate tricks.
Right?
And uh,
in New York.
Crazy dude,
she brought me to her quote unquote
dungeon shelia fancy gimp suit.
No,
I,
she liked it.
That was kind of dominant because I
don't know if you guys know I'm an alpha
male,
but she had a chair that I tell you
this.
I did this.
She had a tear.
Yeah.
You could tie your balls.
Yeah,
go ahead.
You'd sit in a chair and theRe was a
hole in the chair and your balls and
cock would hang between the chair.
Oh,
I bet she would put a a a ring at the
base of your life where you're cocking
your balls,
meat and then you'd be chained to the
floor and then she'd do whatever the
fuck she wanted.
When she said that her biggest clientele
were all lawyers.
Mostly lawyers.
There were something about lawyers like
to be dominant.
Did she kick you in the balls?
Be a.
I didn't do with you today.
There's a lot of.
Those guys brought me there.
Sometimes they're super superintendent
seeing those videos.
brian,
both they're guys.
When I worked at the strip club as a dj,
there was guys that would come in and
they would sit in the lap dance booth
and want the girls in nam and the ball
fuck is wrong with them.
That was one a year.
Every year.
One free.
Sure.
Some guys like to be caught.
They liked to be electrocuted,
like to like to feel.
I think there's also some real
scientific inquiry into this and they
think there's some people feel pain
differently.
I mean if you're.
If you can be born with something wrong
with your body,
right?
If you could be born with some sort of a
birth defect,
why can't you be born with some sort of
a defect in the way your body senses
pain and apps?
We're just assuming like,
you know,
I don't like pain.
You don't like pain.
He's like,
fuck payments.
be off with everybody.
I think some people are numb and pain
gives them like a vital shot in the arm
to let them know they're still alive.
That's why people a lot of depressed
people like tattoos.
Yeah.
According to richard,
Richard Walter,
who's a big time profiler for sadism,
he's guy wrote the double helix
basically on,
on serial killers and what makes,
how a serial killer becomes,
you know,
and he solves a lot of these cold cases,
but he's an fbi profiler,
deals with the worst cases,
like the real,
the real estate.
And he said every,
it's always so certain.
So there,
there,
there's certain people that get off on
the act of killing,
right?
And in fact they'll almost kill you then
bring it back to life.
The real sick fuckers.
But he said all of those people eat
including cannibals and things.
They all are getting a sexual charge out
of whatever it is.
It is.
They Do.
So regardless,
it's not,
it's power over the person,
but according to him,
there's always,
yeah,
there's always a sexual drive for us.
So yeah,
like the one guy who they found,
uh,
this terry was a cannibal and he
couldn't,
he killed,
killed his two wives and they caught him
because he,
you know,
he just would do all these terrible
things and he couldn't feel when you
found him,
he had add happens.
I think that this is in the forties,
fifties.
They had hat pins in his ass and his
balls.
He had pins in his balls and hat pins
stuffed in his ass and he was walking
around and he said that basically he had
trouble feeling anything,
anything.
And so he would stick these needles in
his balls and they found him with
that's.
They're like,
wait,
why do you kill an eight people?
You torture people.
What?
Let's start with your mother.
Well wait a minute,
you got hat pins in your asshole.
Did you hear about the guy in Canada?
Her balls brought the guy in Canada that
had a mental episode on a bus and they
brought a knife with him in bags like
plastic bags.
Killed this guy cut his head off with a
knife and then eight his eyeballs on the
bus beheaded,
a guy on a crowded bus.
People on the bus,
they were sleeping.
It was late at night at this guys
fucking head off eight his eyes,
they deemed him mentally ill.
They gave him medication and they just
released them.
Hello Canada part of Canada,
windsor can do shows.
Windsor,
ontario.
Where was it?
Where was it says manitoba.
Manitoba,
sorry.
Woke up.
Toba.
Uh,
I don't know if people woke up or not,
but there was,
there was cops that were outside while
he was.
The guy was already dead and he was
eating.
There was cops and first responders that
wound up committing suicide apparently.
See if that's true,
but that's what I had read,
that it was such a gruesome horrific
scene that some first responders
committed suicide,
but people like I,
I got in like debate with people online
about this.
They're like,
look,
he had a psychotic episode as long as he
takes his medication will be fine,
and I was like,
well,
even if that's the case,
the fact that someone could ever in
their existence and their time and their
consciousness on earth be capable of
sawing someone's head off with a knife
and then eating their eyeballs on a bus.
you can't ever let them out of your
sight because he never did that until he
did it once.
He never did that until he did it once
and then he did it once.
Now you know he can do it,
so for you to let him go,
I don't care what you say about mental
illness that is so irresponsible,
irresponsible,
and not have a relapse.
We don't know how to react to the
medication.
IT never happened before.
Then it happened,
which means it can happen.
I feel the same way about pedophiles.
If you,
if you,
if you raped a child and you go through
all the therapy in the world,
I don't care.
I pay it.
I can't let you in.
The audience are so fucking nice
tonight.
That's what it is,
that people ate the eyeballs and didn't
know any better.
He feels bad.
It feels super bad.
my bat to the nice canadians are the
nicest people I've ever come across.
I think they're the nicest nature.
Pretty cool.
They're amazing.
They're so fucking nice.
Yeah,
and that's how something like that flies
over there.
They have a social justice warrior
president or prime minister trudeau.
He's hilarious,
like the refugees get sad.
Do you know gavin?
Yeah.
Well god has been,
you know,
he lives up there in montreal.
He's a professor in montreal and he just
highlights all the ridiculous policies
that this guy keeps promoting and the
stuff that he gets behind and the things
that he.
I mean he,
he like what they're doing up there is
like,
it's really strange.
You can get arrested if you say things
about certain people,
like they don't have freedom of speech
the way we have it.
They have like these human rights
councils that decide whether or not you
should be able to do shit.
Hey,
so if you get heckled by some lesbians,
you call him a dirty dyke and say go eat
her asshole.
You dirty bitch or say something crazy
like that.
You could get arrested and then sued and
lose and that happened in vancouver.
He says there's lot.
They have crazy laws as far as like
using gender pronouns back that Jordan
Peterson,
Jordan Pearson is a big part of that
push back.
Without him,
a lot of that would have just been
swallowed up by the academics.
He's one of the first academics to stand
up and go,
hey guys,
this is fucking crazy and this is just
controlling people and when you start
controlling people like this,
it goes down this dirty road and this
dirty road is a dictator.
There's dirty road is like ideologies
and dominating your patterns of speech
and the whole marketplace of somebody
say genda exactly what the agenda of
equality that great fuzzy in topeka and
the sky and if you listen to Jordan
Peterson,
he knows so much about marxism that it
shows you like,
oh,
this is a pattern of human thinking.
It starts off by people that were really
well intentioned.
they're intellectuals,
they're very kind,
they're sympathetic,
they're progressive,
and they want everyone to be nice,
so one of the ways they do it is to be
really evil to people they think are not
nice,
and then you create this fucking war
because they look at them as predators
and they're sort of like infantiles
date.
The problem is that people on the other
side don't look at it that way.
So you're starting this thing and you're
creating to shored up defenses in walls
of offense.
You,
you start,
you push in,
you start multisoft cocktail and
universities that have given speeches by
guys who were republicans.
You create a like that.
Uc Berkeley.
What happened with milo?
I didn't get pulled them out of the
fucking building to save his life like
people are writing.
Did $100,000
with a damage to the school forward
thinking.
I thought.
I thought berkeley was so tolerant on
what a surprise.
As long as you don't fire.
They made cars.
Portland milo was there and so he got
shot sometimes shy by us.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
it's crazy and if you listen to what
he's saying,
he's saying some racist shit,
right?
Not nothing compared to the reaction.
Then it's getting nothing.
He's mostly a half of a troll.
He's like half of a comedian when he
says things,
he's bitchy.
He's a bitchy gay guy,
the column a nazi and he's a fucking gay
jew.
It is one of the funniest things ever.
They're calling this guy nazi and a
white supremacist slogan of his tour
though.
It's 10th a dangerous faggot tour,
but he,
he's gay,
and he talks about his love of black
dick.
You know,
he taLks about how the system,
he's a writer and a troll,
but like an intelligent troll and a
british guy who's got people on.
If you look at what they said it was
because he said a rude,
racist shit organized some sort of an
attack on leslie jones,
but he didn't do it.
Like,
if you look at what he said,
if,
if how responsible is someone who cracks
a joke about someone.
Like he said something about leslie
jones wouldn't be the first time I was.
I was turned down by a black man,
like,
like something along those lines like
bitchy but funny.
And for that,
just for that,
for saying that,
because she was mad at his review or
something like that,
was his followers started sending her
horrible come maybe,
but what,
how much of that can you push onto him?
He can't control that.
You can't control it.
So I'm not with what I'm saying is if
you look at what he actually said,
if that's grounds for a band,
we're dealing with some extreme
censorship.
So you've got to figure out like when is
he responsible?
So he did he say,
hey guys,
go get him.
no he didn't,
but you know who did do that is leslie
jones.
There was a tweet where leslie jones,
someone was attacking her and she was
like,
go get them to that person.
Like to.
Which is like,
look,
that's her prerogative too.
If you want to be a cut.
And started attacking this woman who's a
very hilarious comedian for no reason.
She,
I think she should be able to say fuck
you and do it publicly and say go get
him her fence.
So my point is my low never said that
milo literally never said go get him,
but yet he was sort of held responsible
for things that other people said,
you can't.
There's so many crazy people out there.
The idea that you can control them and
then you could just like say like people
who like bryan county,
you are responsible for those people.
You have to set a good example.
We're going to kick you off our
platform.
That's essentially what they're saying.
Crazy sweared Their prerogative,
but pull up to what he asks.
I think it's interesting.
you know that you're not going to change
that.
We always have to remember that if you
disagree with the other side,
the idea is to try to get them to agree
with you or try to come up with some
kind of a consensus so you can move
ideas forward to move the world forward.
And what we have with this kind of
reaction to milo is if you're going to
do $100,000
worth of damage in your protest,
well that's fine and milo have to be
escorted out and you won't listen to
them and you close your mind.
You're not moving anything forward or
making anything better though.
You're juSt creating a big old division.
And I guess you guys can stay in your
echo chamber.
They all stay in their echo chamber and
nobody will listen to each other and we
won't learn anything.
Well that's just a product of being
raised in this system,
this two party system and this
ridiculous idea that there's us and them
and now that they're in,
there's this,
you know,
all people have to fight back and you
have to punch nazis.
So this crazy shit that people are
saying.
But when you listen to what milo
actually says,
even if you disagree with them,
which I do all the time,
like I disagree witH a lot of what he's
saying.
Ha,
there's sam harris put it best.
He's like,
half of it is like a performance.
It's like he seems insincere a lot of
the times and he's very acutely aware
that is generating response and the
things that he's saying that they're
like,
you know,
that they're saying that he's racist or
he's just,
it's terrible white nationalists or
something like this is just making stuff
up so that they can start attacking him
more freely because it's easier.
What he said is definitely
controversial.
Controversial he said is some of it is
definitely rude.
Some of it is preposterous.
Some of it doesn't make any sense.
Like he's,
he's pro circumcision because he doesn't
want dicks to have extra skin hanging
off of him.
He says he'll fight with you about it.
You know,
he's,
he's a catholic.
I think he is.
I'm like,
okay.
I Believe that.
He's like,
absolutely,
catholicism is the best religion.
it's the moSt amazing religion.
I'm super,
like,
he's crazy.
Okay.
So you started making in front of jones
and we wrote an article.
First of all,
let's say one thing that he wrote an
article,
uh,
where he did a horrible,
mean critique of the new ghost busters
for women.
and he said essentially that it was like
a feminist film and he pointed out some
really important shit.
He's like,
every guy in the movie is a fucking
idiot and every woman's saves the world.
And he's like,
it's kind of ridiculous.
So he,
he says,
I'm so he writes this.
So she was getting hate mail from his
response,
I guess from his thing,
racial abuse that she was getting.
And he said,
everyone gets hate mail for fuck's for
fuck sake.
One tweet read another one called jones,
barely literate.
Later,
she shared fake screenshots.
Oh,
he shared frakes screenshots that made
it appear of jones.
We're making profane and offensive
postings.
Twitter didn't saY exactly why it band.
He annapolis only telling breitbart
writer that he was permanently banned
for violation of the company's rules
prohibiting participation in or exciting
targeted use of individuals.
So what makes that like,
okay,
I could see like if he was post
retweeting things that,
that were very rude,
I would love to see what those things
were.
Probably pretty see how rude they were.
Maybe they were silly.
they were racist.
They were bad,
they were bad,
they were crazy.
They're all making it appear.
That was jones link there,
jamie.
Scroll back down.
See where it says it.
Made it appear of jones.
We're making profane and offensive
postings.
Click on that.
Let's see what it looks like.
What it.
What was actually said.
This was not me.
Okay.
Uncle tom.
Fag nero needs to get his racist ass
out.
My mentions shit like this makes me
think we need to gas these goddamn
faggots to death.
Okay,
so that's not really her fake.
Yeah.
Somebody made a fake.
That's kind of fucked up to do to leslie
jones.
Terrible.
Well,
how do we know?
Okay.
You got to assume that he knew that that
wasn't him.
He posted one that that wasn't her
brother.
Right.
But hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
We got.
Assume that.
Go back to that again,
jamie.
you got to assume that he knew that that
wasn't really hard.
Right?
You don't think that he really thought
she wrote that.
so if he retweets that,
if that's a fake account,
what's the dif?
Okay,
so it's just a photo that someone put it
or did he.
Someone else did it and he tweeted it.
He retweeted it,
I guess.
Okay.
So let's see what the other ones are.
Although it says it looks like it's
verified as well as dog.
Did he retweet this?
If someone sent it to him and he.
He retweeted it.
Okay.
Here's one less dog.
You're ghostbusters just in the first to
have an opening.
Oh shit.
Super racist.
Whoa.
It's awful.
So he retweeted that.
He retweeted that.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's not cool.
That's pretty fucking rude.
Okay.
What,
what else we got?
That's,
that's,
that's just shitty man that I not like.
Just that makes me want to put this on
him.
He's definitely got some issues.
She's lashing,
he's got some fucking issues.
We were good.
We get it.
You get it.
Well that's.
He's definitely got some issues like
that.
That's not a cool thing to do,
but what he's doing,
he insights talk and because of that,
his.
His book is now number one on the amazon
piece trying to accomplish what's the
book property sale and no one knows it
has books not even out yet.
Yeah.
It's really,
really interesting guy in a lot of ways.
He's very smart.
I talked to him off air.
He's a very intelligent guy.
He's very cordial,
very good to talk to.
I really enjoyed talking to him and we
joked around a lot when we did the
podcast together because I grilled them
about certain things I think are
ridiculous and eventually gives them.
Starts laughing with you.
He's a very smart guy,
but I don't know what he's doing.
I don't know if this is a real as the
real him or if this is him doing a
performance or if it's combination of
both or if he's finding himself in the
midst of this hurricane of negativity
and popularity,
which would it be just assuming that
he's bullet proof that he can't be
influenced by this fucking crazy or deal
that he's
going through and occasionally do shit
that he shouldn't have done.
like reposting some horrible racist
thing.
He's young.
I mean he's maybe 30 something.
Right?
How old is he made a point.
That's a really interesting point you
just said that made about if this is
like in transition like so.
Sure he is.
He's a growing just like all of us are
and even like it depends on how you can
catch somebody in,
in a moment where they can sound if you
already sound like themselves.
So he's young.
He's fucking smart dude.
I'm telling you.
I believe it.
I just feel like,
yeah,
I definitely disagree With retweeting
that racist picture of leslie jones
looking like a gorilla.
This one guy who said something,
he was at the when,
what was the theater in France that they
shot up during a performance?
He was in the band,
I believe christ.
Remember when?
When those guys opened fire,
the fatal famous famous,
yeah,
death,
metal,
whatever.
And he said something about islam right
after that.
He was like,
he's in and he was emotional and people
had died and it was this concert and he
saw some all kinds of stuff and he said
something that they picked up and he did
an inteRview because they just did a
documentary on it and he said something
really interesting.
They said,
you said something about islam,
do you have any regret about that?
And it was pretty racist.
And he saId,
alright,
well look,
first of all,
I love people.
We have a lot of muslims fans and
anything else said what happened there
was my emotions were so heightened and
there was a,
there was a span of time where I was
thinking in a very emotional,
uncharacteristic way that I usually am
my.
I had,
I was hot off of something tragic and I
didn't even know how to make sense of it
to.
I don't want you to reread what I said
because that's not who I am,
but in that sliver of time,
that's how I was feeling and I lashed
out in paint.
It's very honest way of putting it is
and I thought that that's why we have to
be careful about taking quotes and then
applying that to a peRson's entire
character.
This was a guy in the band after he.
He said something about islam,
but.
But it made me think about that.
We do this all the time where we say,
you said that one thing you said a
sentence,
let's,
let's highlight that and let's just say
that's who the man is.
You know,
you gotta be careful.
So sometimes you'll be held accountable
for what you're tweeting.
You're doing well.
We can't always give everyone a pass,
but all he's just going through a rough
time.
It's all good.
It's held accountable too.
That's true too.
That's true too,
but we also have to recognize that like
at 33 years of age,
especially,
dude,
I was a moron when I was 33 and if I had
gotten drunk and I decided to retweet
some shit,
thank god twitter wasn't arounD theN I
want to say the student is that young
and if he's a smart,
yes it is.
We say stupid shit all the time.
Who was doing stupid shit.
I've know.
Retweet anything raCist.
Thirty three.
Oh,
you're not racist,
but with him,
this is a pattern.
Maybe you don't get a free.
Here's the thing,
man.
He's his whole thing is courting
controversy.
That's essentially what he's doing by
saying feminism is cancer.
He's
organizing a fistfight,
he's calling them out and he's
organizing a verbal fiscal saves
probably on adderall,
so he's talking to 100 miles an hour.
He's really articulate and he's gay and
he looks fabulous and he's got bleached
blonde hair and he wears clothes and
when he's killing it,
like on stage,
he's a very good orator.
So he's engaging them in these debates
that he's got carefully thought out,
responses,
carefully thought out sentences.
He definitely knows what he's doing.
He definitely knows what he's talking.
How was your conversation with Henry
Rollins?
Speaking of articles,
kitten little pony with this racism
thing.
Oh,
I love that.
He's a good looking guy.
Handsome fellow.
Hell yeah.
It's profound love of black dick.
He talks about all the time,
which is also one more way that they
have a hard time attacking him because
he's a gay jew that loves black dick.
Like he's got the spectrum covered.
He's like,
there's a triangle sensibility that's
around him.
Brian's.
These are good talking.
One time brian know you're all right
man.
I think you can't.
This is.
This is what fascism is.
You can't enforce your view of the world
on people through violence because
that's what you're doing when you're a
fascist and that's what people need to
understand.
Like you can't just use the word fascist
when it applies to right wing people.
If you're keeping people from
communicating,
you're keeping a gay jew from talking
shit on your stage and you can't just
counter what he saying with someone
who's better at talking shit.
That is better points.
So instead you want to throw a chair
through the window at fucking starbucks.
Look,
stop.
You guys are fascist,
fascist.
Even if you think you're right,
the way you're doing it is 100 percent
wrong.
This isn't the guys on a nazi.
He's not someone who's,
even if he has said a racist thing in
the past,
he's not the first.
Every fucking comedian has said racist
shit.
let's Dog herself had a bunch of racist
They pulled off her twitter page.
We don't hate her for that.
She had a bunch of shit about white
people.
Just generalizing about white people in
general.
If you ever did that about black people,
you would get blackballed from hollywood
for life of course.
But we will allow a certain amount of
stupid shit to come out of people's
mouths if we think that you're not a bad
person.
Yeah,
and if you disagree,
if you disagree wiTh somebody where you
beat it,
I'll say it again.
The way you beat a bad idea is with
which you don't do,
is you don't start this fucking meme of
punch nazis.
like everybody keeps saying punch nazis
like,
don't say that.
You're talking shit on there though.
You see that girl get maced in the face
and the girl with the shit up make
bitcoin great again hat and they came up
at mesa mesa in the face because it
looked like a make America great again.
She fucked up.
it doesn't matter man.
They fucked up.
Guy peter in the head with a sign and
another guy macer in the face.
The ruthless to they weren't ruthless
with is our boy jake shields.
He was at the protest that didn't get
maced.
He's lucky to get maced in the face on
the trailer.
You need more.
You need more than mace to fight.
Jake shields got problem with macy's.
You can't see.
And if people just jump on you,
you can't look.
Jacob,
probably jack,
90 percent of them that come anywhere
near him you can't see and someone hits
you over the back of the head with
something.
Yeah.
These fucking people are doing exactly
what they would hate.
And when I see people,
like there's people that are calling out
for who they're calling out for a
military coup,
they're calling out for them.
I've seen more than one person say this,
like the military needs to step in and
take our country back.
And I'm like,
holy shit,
this is patrick swayze movie from the
eighties.
They're thinking exactly the way of
fastest would or a tyrant would.
They just have a different target.
But that's what I always say to people.
It's amazing how many people think
exactly like their enemy,
exactly like their enemy.
I want to kill all of them or whatever.
And yet they're just.
The only difference is they have a
different target.
But it's crazy when you have a
legitimate contest,
right?
You had a legitimate popularity contest
and one guy wins and you're not happy
that the guy wins.
So you want to start riots like you
might.
You might have fucked up and not voted,
or you might not have done such good job
picking a candidate or you might have
had the wrong campaign,
but you have to accept when someone
wins.
Otherwise there's no fucking point.
And having his contest,
we have this contest every four years
and if you don't accept to one,
as long as it's not this,
the cheating,
whatever the cheating happened,
it probably happened on both sides.
Whatever legal shit they got away with
whatever shenanigans and the pr they did
to him with the whole,
uh,
grab them by the pussy thing and all
that.
I mean,
there's,
there's a tax left and right on both
sides.
He came out ahead.
People aren't happy.
I might understand that people aren't
happy,
but you can't think that you can start a
riot now because you didn't want him to
be in there.
They had a stupid fucking contest.
he won stupid fucking contest.
The problem is you're having a stupid
fucking contests to see who runs the
world.
And also it's important to have a little
compassion for the other side in this
terms.
Like I constantly hear trump voters
being characterized as homophobes
rednecks,
dumb hillbillies and all that stuff
because they're in there.
They're in the mix.
There's always there.
And they're there.
They're in the mixing on both sides,
the categories.
Here's the thing,
it might also be worth taking a little
bit of a human approach and looking at
trump voters and um,
maybe a lot of trump voters may be a lot
of trump voters who are good people
didn't like trump that much either,
but they liked hillary way less or maybe
hillary's talking the way obama has been
for the past eight years and their lives
haven't changed for,
and they were desperate to seat anything
else.
Work,
be a little compassionate on why a lot
of people voted for trump because
remember this country voted a black
president in and a lot of those voters
were white,
uh,
t two times in a row.
Well,
but in order for him to have one,
you have to have some people that voted
for obama last term that voted for trump
this.
correct.
There's a lot of people that thought it
would be a better thing to have him
other than her.
Yeah.
so there were no racist.
They're not all,
you know,
homophobes they,
they were.
That's why I was always really careful
about.
I was always critical of trump.
I was very careful not to be critical of
trump voters because you know there are
a lot,
but you're not being honest because
there are dummies in there too,
just like there's dummies in the.
Hillary cannot present there on this.
That's why those stereotypes exist.
When you talk about the latte sipping
hillary supporters who literally know
nothing about what the negative things
she's Done.
If you say anything about or you're a
sexist,
I mean there's a lot of that going on
too.
Those are real people like the real
ridiculous people on the left and the
right.
They're all real.
You know,
so the hillbillies that love trump.
Look dude,
I've seen it,
man.
I saw a video where this guy got pulled
over in an altercation with this guy hit
and this other guy had gotten some sort
of a traffic altercation and this guy
comes uP to his window.
He's calling them the n word and he's
saying,
trump,
man,
I'm with trump.
Trump's president now.
And it's that type of person that like
there.
There are people like that that want to
let you know that this is their guy now
because they're white and that this is
like a racist thing.
You think their races winning.
Think there was kkk people that voted
for hillary,
like a special group kkk for hillary.
The kkk people are there like.
Let's be honest,
how many just straight up racists and
how many kkk?
P 2000 official kkk takes.
There are a lot of 200,000.
I thought I saw that sounds.
I wouldn't doubt if there was a million
in the south.
I think there's definitely probably a
million racists.
I'm trying to fish clan members.
Joining an organization's on knowing how
many ufc fans are.
There is a lot,
but if you had to join an organization
to be a ufc fan will be far less of us
mean buying the paper,
review the hood and go to a fucking
flame.
Had to go to a bonfire.
5,000.
What more than 40 different clan groups
exist.
Many having multiple chapters or clavier
burns.
That's cute and cute and a few that a
presence in a large number of states.
There are over a hunDred different klan
chapters around the country with the
combined strength in members and
associates that made total around
$5,000.
Oh my god.
they're a little bigger than 10th
planet.
Bigger.
That is so crazy.
I don't even know if they're smart
enough to be anything.
I think that they are.
A lot of times People are just sort of
guys who want to be part of a group and
you know,
they.
They've been told something,
they don't do any research and they're
just dicks and there a lot of just
shitheads who want to be part of a hate
group.
A lot of problem with black versus white
is the same problem as left versus
right.
Black versus white,
left versus right.
Share that fucking team thing,
man.
They share that team thing and white
people want to think that they're on one
team.
Black people want to think they're on
another team and we fuck each other up
doing that.
It's so human.
Human,
human,
human beings are very tribal.
I mean,
anthropologists tell you that all the
time,
that human beings are tribal.
EveryThing.
It's about time,
like this generation is cut that shit.
No,
this is literally not.
What do you mean?
But I'll tell you,
I don't think it's aBout time.
You know,
with jared diamond who's,
who wrote guns,
germs and steel,
great,
amazing guy.
And he Said that he fascinating that
when they were studying different tribes
in papa new Guinea that had been
isolated so they were,
they weren't really influenced By
western culture at all.
And what would happen was they have two
tribeS that would get along really well
and they even inner married and you
know,
they,
they shared things and everything else
and as soon as there became scarce
resources like water or game and one
side's very existence started to get
threatened for.
So for example,
maybe this one tribes closer to a water
source and the other water source dried
up.
So what'll happen is it's really
amazing.
It's very quickly the tribes will start
making up stories about each other.
Yeah.
We've talked about this before on
another podcast.
Know we talked about this,
you talked about how they decided in a
very short amount of time the other
people were bad and they went over and
kill.
Yeah.
So I think that's human nature,
man.
And I think when you start talking about
getting along,
you can't afford certain people you can
know.
That's the whole point.
Like right now,
life has never been easier.
So what I'm saying is it's about time
that this generation like figure out the
people are just people that it's fucking
stupid for all redheaded people to join
together and form clan,
you know,
fellow people working.
I agree with that.
It's just getting through.
It is,
it,
is it,
it's more getting through today I think
than ever before in history because
there's one that,
right?
Yeah.
Because it's like,
even like if you go back and watch those
old bugs bunny cartoons,
you know which ones they don't show
something that's funded by your will.
They don't show that dude that much.
I bet they showed a lot and they don't
show.
They don't show pepe le pew fogbugz
rapists gun ugly feeling.
That's gunk is a rapist.
Motherfucker will fuck that cat members,
so fucking ridiculous.
It was just trying to kill that cat.
Always imagine if you went outside a
skunk was trying to fuck your cat,
like your favorite cat and some wild
skunk.
Just all sweet cathy.
Pet behind her ears and you love her is
dirty skunk.
This fucking chicken.
Eat and monsters conceIt.
Chickens.
By the way,
here they break into chicken coop,
so I caught one trying to get into my
chicken coop.
Carnivorous.
There are 100 percent predator skunks
are predators.
I didn't know that.
Yeah,
we think of them as the ground nesting
birds.
Rats,
rodents,
chickens.
The fuck up your chicken.
I'll get in.
He couldn't get in.
We chased them off though.
He stunk up my whole fucking yard.
Yeah,
we know how to show.
Showed me the deer eating the birds that
were stuck in the fence.
yeah,
the birds.
Isn't it weird that you could be driving
on the god damn freeway with your
windows rolled up eric tight and pass
through a cloud of skunk smell?
How does it do the gods?
I'll tell you exactly how the same way
the with the skunk smells so strong that
your reaction to it is like a bloodhound
reaction to persons sent like
electricity when you.
That's how we can understand like how
bloodhound works and probably
bloodhounds probably even better than
that,
but parts per million.
Whether or not you can detect it.
Skunk smells so bad that in parts per
million they can shoot it in the
backyard and you could smell it like
literally a mile away.
Wow.
Well that's how a dog works.
Yeah,
like a good bloodhound.
They'll fucking smell you a mile away.
They just got to figure out where it's
coming from.
They'll run that way.
Nope.
It's getting weaker.
they'll go run that way stronger.
I think it's electro.
It's a smell.
It smell.
It's hard to go through the glass.
So jetson.
Well,
how do you breed that?
He would run out of air if that thing
was airtight.
Do you understand that you're coming
into your filter's not airtight?
Well,
how come you don't feel it when you're
driving?
Because it goes through a whole system
that's inside your dash breach?
No,
no,
it gets backed up,
it gets backed up and then it comes
through filters.
Like you can open the filters to the
vents,
come through and then you can actually
feel the breeze blow on you when you're
on the highway where you can close that
shit.
But air still gets in.
He gets into the cabinet.
I'm saying,
I'm going to guess that it's electrical.
Well,
you should definitely guess driving a
flintstone.
Coach burns by my online.
We have libraries.
She'd go online with your phone.
Just stay off youtube.
You're that your slave.
Stay off flat earth.
Sixty nine.
Youtube made by slave labor.
I'm not going to throw this away to
prove that.
I don't believe in slate made these
phones.
What was the name of that company that
made like,
um,
phones that were sustainably resourced
and what was the company called?
It was like ethical phones.
They like,
they tried to make some green phone or
it's okay man,
this guy makes 50 bucks an hour and
everybody's happy.
Well,
isn't that a family?
Is they work three days a week?
They said anyway,
isn't that isn't the material used?
Isn't that mined in the Congo?
The sticks?
Yes.
LittlE kids with sticks have to pull it
out of the rocks.
It's called tran.
I got to talk to my mom.
They get it in a couple of different
places,
I guess where else to get it?
Afghanistan and they found trillions of
dollars worth of minerals in
Afghanistan.
Hey guys,
we just.
I can't believe this is here.
Amazing.
It's like they.
It's like they had a like a whole x on a
fucking map the russians were doing.
We were digging.
Then finally they,
hey guys,
can't even believe this,
but guess what?
There's like trillions of dollars worth
of minerals here.
I bet they're just saying that they're
just there for the opium and they're
like,
no,
there's minerals here.
Unless we struck minerals.
See,
this is where there's a flaw in your
thinking.
They're going to take both of those
things.
They want it.
They want both of those things.
The mother opium for fucking sure.
Sturgill simpson played a song on
saturday night live about the opium
trade,
like they let them get away with it,
but talking about how Afghanistan as
like a front front run by production,
it's also a country music star,
so they're like,
oh,
that's all good.
You killed it on the ground.
A lot of poppies,
bad motherfucker,
dude.
Say grow 96 percent of the world's opium
that we were over there.
Yeah,
for sure.
Just for like freedom freedom.
We don't care about opium or even
minerals.
Those minerals here.
Wow.
Amazing.
We pulled out,
but we're going to leave behind a
vacuum.
Big ass it to a battleship.
We're going to fill that motherfucker up
with every six months.
Scroll heroin in the United States.
Greenhouses.
No.
Hold on.
What is that jamie?
Would you pull up extra cost to make
google phone in the us?
Only four bucks.
Holy shit.
That's not the iphone.
The iphone would cost to a moto x.
Oh,
years ago in the bathroom.
Okay,
well that's four bucks.
More on the biggest cost that says is
that there's a.
In China,
they have at least maybe in one plant.
They're up to 30,000
industrial engineers to help the
workers.
if something goes wrong,
they're saving mad cash and they also
know what the fuck they're doing.
They've been doing it for a long time.
if you started that up in the United
States,
like there'd be a lot of trial and
error.
You'd have to be willing to throw away a
lot of money.
The phones would be shit.
Come on now.
Think about it.
Feel like an american car in the
eighties.
The iphone in America first to build it
now costs $2,000.
You're right,
but what does the cross now it costs a
thousand,
right?
Well,
no.
Now the phone's like $700.
That's the comparison that.
What is an iphone seven s?
What does that crossed?
They haven't made that seven plus rather
sorry.
The next one.
Are they going to ever bring that back?
But you can get an adapter or use
adapters.
You know you get a lightning adapter,
sticks it in as a regular hole in the
bottom of it.
I heard that the iphone eight,
there's supposed to be flipped capable
of bring about the flip flip.
That's going to make it a book no plugs
to.
It's all wireless charging,
which is maybe or maybe not true,
right?
It's going to be terrible with
electricity is going to be in the air.
We're all going to die.
That's when tesla was talking about
putting electricity in the air.
You create habitat out there like radio.
You're gonna generate things.
We're going to be walking around with
like tesla coils bouncing off of that
could have been real if they already
aren't we already walking through a sea
of electricity.
There's definitely a lot of electricity
around us and there's definitely wifi in
this room.
We might be in the ocean of electro
magnetism,
right?
Yeah,
bro.
Think about that.
What's powering your muscles?
Your muscles are pounding.
You lucked into some electrical outlet.
Well,
you know what it is.
Electricity is definitely a part of us.
There's a lot of shit going on.
There's water that's important.
Electricity that conducts through the
water.
There's all the vitamins.
Jeff city in us,
jesus,
jc,
but the love of running on wireless
electricity.
Sure.
We're watching like a bunch of cricket
phones.
What do you do?
You think that wifi and cell phone
signals and all the signals that are
around us all the time,
they just didn't exist when people were
first created by hippie.
Good lord.
How bad is it?
No one's.
We're not dying.
We have no idea.
Because remember the bluetooth they'd
put to your ear like,
I probably shouldn't do that.
Or didn't they find that cell phones
were bad sleep next to and put it next
to your ear?
Yeah.
People say that it fucks with your
karma.
She one of them.
One of them things.
Well,
what happened to brain tumors the day
they let that go?
Is that real?
But hidden.
What's her name?
The fucking singer.
Didn't she have?
Um.
All I want to do,
he just has that sheryl crow.
Didn't sheryl crow say that she got a
brain tumor from doing press on a cell
phone and the nineties she thinks that.
So gave it to her because it's on the
same side of her head kind of fucking
press tour where you.
It's crazy.
I talked to him.
I talked to a dude who had cancer of his
bone and his hip.
And it was right where he kept a cell
phone and the doctor said that there's
reoccurring instances that he's dealing
with with people had cell phones.
Scotty get a bone graft,
bro,
get a cut of counselors side.
They had a cancerous chunk of his bone
off and then they had to put a bone
graft from somewhere else in there and
fill it back in place.
And he was saying that this doctor was
telling them that all these guys that
come in and they have those hip things
for cell phones,
like that's the side where they would
get cancer.
Most girls usually put the phone in
their back pocket.
You're going to see a lot of asks cancer
tumors.
Tumors could be.
I wonder if we get some dick,
but when your fingers get the most
tumors,
where's the hand cancer?
My hands feel good.
It just doesn't seem to be bothering
anybody else.
Let's get enhanced cancer.
You know,
maybe just got a weak hip bone.
You fucking pussy.
You maybe need to walk it off.
Yeah.
Maybe it's just incidents as shit.
Goddamn cell phone to your hip.
Like a psycho.
But did you see sheryl crow?
Did you find that article?
She actually had cancer and she didn't
want to get the tumor removed.
Whoa.
But she got an inner dome on the same
side is where a cell phone was and
that's why she thought that it was from
doing press.
She get to go hippo face.
How dare you?
Back when there was no internet,
you know.
And you had to do press for radio or for
radio.
And you had to do press for an album
that was coming out.
Yeah.
You just call people up and do
interviews.
That's what they.
That's what you did.
Leave this sheryl crow.
My brain tumor maybe related to cell
phone use.
See the chosen fucked up picture or
tuition.
What's been trumped that doug just
fucking spray or no doctors that will
confirm that crow said monday.
Well appealing on the premier of katie.
The new syndicated talk show hosted
hosted by katie couric.
Hilarious.
I do have a theory that it's possible
that it's related to that she spent
hours on the old archaic cell phones.
Well,
she's probably right.
There's no doctors that will even
confirmed it's part of a brain where she
often held her phone.
Have you ever noticed,
have you ever been.
Let's talk you up to something else,
but it might be true be,
but it could be that that's what
happened.
That's totally possible that she had
that phone up to her head and broader
brand stretch.
More about what your.
Maybe there's a couple of days maybe
there a cover to cover and there's a lot
of people are trying to test it on.
Here's.
Yeah,
here's the other.
No,
I'm just guessing,
but radiation.
The doctor.
We're to just talk over them.
Are you gonna?
Let them talk.
I'm listening to him,
but he's gay.
He's getting me thinking about something
because he's got them out here.
You go like a cover up.
Jesus christ.
He was in the middle of the talk.
I would just force over.
I'm just bullshitting.
Well,
you might be right.
Maybe the grappler on.
I just want to know what happened to
that.
I mean you would think it is.
I would believe that it is dangerous.
I don't know,
but maybe it's not.
I hope it's not,
oh,
that's all bullshit.
But I mean,
does anybody fucking.
No where they haven't been around that
long.
Like how long have people been using
cell phones?
The way we're using them now where
you're constantly on them.
Twenty years.
Has it been eight years now?
I remember yet.
Twenty minutes.
Smartphones,
smartphones were the thing that did it.
Was it o seven?
Zero.
Eight?
Yes.
So from then on people are like slowly
but surely getting more and more
integrated into using that electronic
device and constantly being either
because before that there was no twitter
or facebook or instagram or any of that
shit.
Yeah,
there was no like answering questions on
google.
So you and also you get taxed and send
calls forever.
Right.
There was no internet until 2007 and
nobody was going online with a trio
piece of shit.
I'm like,
yeah,
it was falling.
That's why black pain was so important
because the email,
no one was on the phone a ton.
Texts actually people have had their
phones at their heads for longer since
like what?
Since probably 92.
No,
sheryl crow became popular in 94.
I remember that because I had just come
to la and all I want to do is have some
fun.
Was like on the radio back then it was a
big jam so those phones were just.
They might as well been plutonium and a
fucking a lot of gold cup where they're
like this.
He held those pitches ahead,
but actually I read this thing about how
when radiation,
like from a phone or whatever,
I guess the idea is that it can break
apart certain like mitochondria or d dna
strand.
What is it,
where it sounds like some bullshit it'll
take.
It disrupts certain from the library,
bro.
I can't remember.
It disrupts things in that process.
Can actually cause sometimes cancer.
So it's pretty hard to kind of draw a
through line because there's so many
different calls to.
So there's the reality that what causes
cancer to use not going to cause cancer
to him.
I'm not going to cause cancer to another
person and my would make you sick.
Everybody's in their own weird
biological makeup.
Oh yeah.
Some people are super susceptible to all
sorts of weird diseases that other
people aren't,
and there's also environmental factors
like maybe what you work is kind of
fucked up too,
but maybe working in a gas station or
something like that,
or you doing the auto repair and you're
fucking breathe it in paint fumes and
shit,
and then on top of that you're dealing
with that,
right?
That that could just be.
It'd be a combination of factors.
It kills your immune system factors
here,
it's like when you smoke cigarettes,
not everybody who smokes even a lot for
a lifetime gets lung cancer.
some people just don't.
They live into their nineties,
smoke considered crazy,
but then there's also the reality of
living anywhere in high population
centers.
You're being poisoned.
Everybody around us is being poisoned,
if not a whole lot to fuck.
Yes,
100 percent.
You come over that hill and you look
down into the valley and everything is
brown as fuck.
You are breathing that you are 100
percent breathe in your household.
You see it when you get down,
but you know how I can tell because
there's a place near,
um,
like there's a place where you drive
over between like topanga and like to
soda,
like that area wHere you could like look
over and you could see tHe mountains
sometimes,
like maybe like when neck coming down to
one [inaudible],
one,
you can see the mountains sometimes and
sometimes you don't see the mouse
defrays the fucking shit hides
mountains,
the snow covered mountains that you
could get lost on and die in and you
don't see it all.
You see brown,
that's digital breathing that.
That's right.
It's been like that forever.
And la,
it's the valley.
It's a whole mixture to but it's way
worse.
It's way worse now than it was like back
when people are on horses and shit been
told me in front of our producer guy,
he said that uh,
before people even settled in southern
California,
the indians called southern California
that landed the smoke smoke or something
like that.
Right.
So,
and you see,
I've noticed this since I was a kid.
Sometimes you can't see the mountains.
There's too much smog and then a storm
happens and then evidence clear and then
it just a cycle it.
I thought that that was.
We were going to come to a day where it
would never clear up.
It would just be so bad after 20 years,
but it's actually way better.
The air quality in los angeles is way
better because cars are way better at
cars are cleaner,
so eventually the wind just.
We'll clean it.
Here's,
here's something real crazy flip
population.
A porsche nine slash 11 turbo.
The air that comes out is cleaner than
the air that goes in.
If you drive it in la.
Wow.
What's really a porsche nine slash 11
turbo.
It's carbon.
It's carbon emissions are so low that
the air that it takes in until those
turbo charges goes through the
combustion engine and comes out the
exhaust is actually cleaner than the air
it's taking in.
How about this crazy statistic?
The average carter,
the average car on the seventies,
it made it more pollution sitting
without its engine on in a driveway
because of fuel of operation than the
average car on the highway today in los
angeles.
That's brand new.
You remember we used to hear the gas
slosh around back there.
Yeah,
like if you had a car,
like an old car and you like took a
turn.
He went a little sideways here.
The gas slosh around fucking shitty car
carburetors before we had catalytic
converters smelled it inside the car.
He had a roll the windows down.
When you're on the highway,
it's not bad,
right?
so magic markers a dig.
That stuff shouldn't be.
They'll smell a sharp.
So anybody that's worried about being
poisoned,
you definitely be employed and we're
breathing in brake dust 100 percent.
It's not good for you and it's gonna.
It's gonna shorten your life and might
only short your life by a few years.
It might make the last few years of your
life more uncomfortable,
but if you go somewhere where this is
not the case,
you go to like fucking deer valley,
Utah.
You go hang out up there and look out
over the mountains.
I'd rather there than live there and my
parents just kill me.
Threatened parents.
That's why I brought it up.
You fucking awesome.
Other.
They love it.
It's beautiful,
man.
It's cool to visit.
No,
the problem is we got to get more cool
people to live up in a place like that.
That's right.
That's what you gotta do.
Like we're in the wrong spot.
Like the people that we know are all
awesome,
but we're definitely in the wrong spot.
The only thing that's good about this
spot is it warm is no bugs,
but the real problem is it's warm.
There's no bugs.
Like one of the reasons why the indians
call this valley to smoke is like fire
is fucking normal for here.
Things are supposed to burn down and
then they build back better.
I mean,
this is like,
it clears out entire forest,
like controlled burns is something that
forest service is due because you have
to burn down a certain amount of the old
shit.
Otherwise it just becomes kindling and
then when the fires do come,
they're unmanageable and then on top of
that,
the carbon needs to fucking be
recirculated into the earth.
Like it's a good thing.
These burns and that was.
That happened for millions of years and
now because there's no burn,
it's like it changes the environment
like this place.
Places that the used to have burns and
now they control them.
Something like the force goes away and
then just go with these big dry ass
grassy shitty areas over hundreds of
years of doing this.
It's,
it's so weird,
man.
It's like the way people live.
We think that we could just stay in one
spot and this spot is going to be fine.
That's never been the case anywhere on
earth switches supposed to move.
We're supposed to be nomadic.
You have to move back to find out,
dude,
you can't stay right next to the ocean.
That fucking that malibu coast is a
joke.
Those people with the fucking.
Oh man pose.
This is my spot.
Bet you're on the edge of the great
water next to you.
He said,
giant monster of water.
It's miles deep.
Three quarters of the surface of the
earth and your life on the edge.
His mind get off.
Don't you?
Frisbee in front of my hedge.
We like pick a spot like some crazy
stupid crap.
It's like locked itself on a reef and
it's claiming to revise its own.
That's what we're like.
We're like standing by the ocean with
your $20,000,000
house in malibu.
Kicking surfers off your front,
but you're by the great water the fuck
out.
Go to the hills at any time.
That could be an earthquake and the big
Wave way to Arizona
to come over the malibu and checked in
the houses out.
fuck yeah.
I lived there for awhile.
You didn't like dude?
No,
no,
no.
My daughter broke her arm at school and
we couldn't stay at this place because
it had staircases that were really steep
and there was one that went down to the
ocean.
It was one of them electric stairs and
it was broken and so it only went like
this.
So you've got a climate like a fucking
ladder.
It was sketcHy as fuck to get down to
the ocean and it just was too dangerous
where her arm was broken.
Yeah.
You love malibu though.
I remember that.
I love the air.
I love the looking at the ocean,
but I don't want to live there.
I don't want to live next to the big
water ties because when you're at high,
this is what happened with me and the
message.
We've got high one night and went
downstairs.
There's this downstairs to this house.
It's like literally the water's coming
in right under carrie and we were
sitting in,
me and her were like looking out the
window and I and I looked on her,
go,
fuck this place.
Fuck this place.
No,
no,
no.
You realize what it really is like when
you're right there at night in a house
overlooking the ocean.
It's real nature reveals itself to you
because you can be really complacent
when you see everything.
See when it's light out,
you see everything,
you look up,
the sun is shining,
the clouds are moving.
You see birds,
you look down at the ocean and you go,
wow,
this is so cool.
It's so calling being by the ocean,
but when you're at night,
it's black and there's nothing out.
Then you realize,
oh my god,
that's all water.
That's all water,
water to do it.
We stayed there and we rented it for
three months.
I stayed there five times.
What part of it?
Because my daughter broke her arm,
but part of me was like,
oh god,
so high that I realized the nature of
it.
It is a big,
dark monster of water.
They're totally unfeeling and teeming
with life.
Oh yeah.
Most likely.
If you look at the habits of nature,
most likely when things become too
dominant,
something comes along and tries to take
them out.
When things take too much from one
environment,
they wind up starving,
are going extinct.
This is like the constant cycle of life,
right?
Fellows.
Here we are standing next to this great
wall of life that will been sucking out
with nets,
kill it,
everything.
Imagine if you could go back 500 years
and just look under the water and see
what it looked like and then go back to
today and look under the water and see
all the fish are gone.
How many fish there must've been
created.
She meant,
you know how clean it must've been
everywhere before we were pumping our
shit and when I was scuba diving into
hedy by a couple months ago.
It is.
You look out and all you see is fucking
schools of fish.
It's like finding the va.
There's no difference.
I swear to god.
You see sharks.
I looked into the literature for sharks
there.
Lemon sharks don't.
Sounds cool.
I was always like,
dude,
it's like tying in with life probably
the whole ocean.
Yeah.
At one point in time,
coral when you touch the coral,
like there are things in the corner like
he,
he told me to just just put your fingers
and it was this big flower was beautiful
and it just disappeared.
It's like a magic thing that it's the
most scuba diving.
I was down there for so long that I
almost got nitrogen poisoning.
Really pleasant way to die actually.
You just go,
you just.
People will take their regular out of,
give it to the fish so they can breathe
and die.
You guys super slim a bitch.
But I was down there for two hours man.
And I'm telling you,
you know,
you never see when you scuba dive.
What fish?
What do you think?
What?
What aniMal do you never see?
Chickens you never see.
Not at blue.
Well you can see whales.
You never see dolphins because they
don't like the bubbles.
And you will.
And I talked to dr.
Has been scuba diving for 40 years.
I said you ever seen dolphins?
He goes,
never now to smart.
Why?
So they see the bubbles and that was
probably like,
I just don't like it.
It sounds like shit.
and then probably they probably don't
like it that you could stay under.
No,
don't go to the top and then get the
fuck out of there.
Yeah,
I don't know.
It's very interesting day.
We saw a whole school of them as soon as
we got up in the water,
they were all.
Well yeah,
those are the little ones to the gray
ones ever seen the malibu all.
Maybe they hunt them.
Melbourne.
I'm sure some people do.
They hunt them because they killed tuna.
That's one of the things that the
japanese do.
They're not really eating them as much
as they're killing them in order to
like.
Because they,
they get it.
Like,
you know,
you've got hundreds of dolphins.
They find a school to another decimated.
So these tuna men,
you know that like they used to.
If you watched jiro dreams of sushi,
have you seen the doc on netflix?
Really interesting.
But one of the things that really struck
me was how he was talking about how when
he first became a sushi chef,
how easy it was to get the tuna and how
much tuna there was and how it stuck
radically diminished.
We got famous.
You silly bitch.
We all weighed in.
Really?
His place is a tiny little ass place.
But I'm talking about from the time he
was a young man.
Now he's like in the seventies or
something like that.
I think he might be dead actually.
No.
Yeah,
his son runs.
Yeah.
He's no longer alive.
He died after the movie.
I think so.
I think he's dead.
I know his son was supposed to go next
in line.
You could have that job.
Miserable.
Yeah.
Everybody's like,
fine.
They find beauty in it.
And I understand.
I watched it.
I get it.
It's,
there is some sort of a beauty and the
meticulous,
meticulous process of creating the
perfect food.
Exhausting though.
Unbelievable.
Uh,
what's the name knit?
What's the fucking doesn't in general
when you're me,
the sushi.
Wait to watch you eat it.
Yeah.
Freaky like,
get the fuck out my face,
man.
I just want to talk to my wife.
Yeah,
I want to do a six month waiting list to
that.
Um,
do you think that that's different
though than eating at a restaurant or
you go to a steakhouse,
the waiter comes,
everybody's pleasant.
It makes the experience better.
You sit there,
you cut up your food,
you have a conversation.
But if you're sitting in front of that
dude,
it's very different.
You gotta be like,
gee,
this is a completely different sort of
experience.
This guy is crafting some sort of
culinary artwork for you in the form of
these bite sized morsels of perfectly
aged fish with a perfect sauce on it
with a perfectly cooked rice and he's
been meticulous about this process for
so long.
Like you're,
you're taking in Some sort of a weird
vibe.
I wouldn't want to do it all the time.
No one wants once every 10 years be
great.
The other thing is you're going to walk
away starving dogs a form of mastery
that you should always experience
[inaudible].
I think it's mastery and artist rates
and fat sushi.
That's trends.
It transcends rice.
Fish,
rice.
You see the documentary.
I know.
Yes.
I did.
Nice fish.
That's like saying anything you can do,
you can simplify it,
but don't you think that life is about
the variety of choices that you have and
it's good that you could go to a place
like this and have these weird bites of
clam mixed with a weird sort of a
seaweed wrap on top of it and some
perfectly cooked rice with a little bit
of you listening to benihana.
right.
So ron is when the steakhouse,
they cook in front of,
you know,
benihana.
They cook in front of that.
This would be like a sweet fish or
sugar.
Sugar fish.
Yeah,
but it's like a little art form.
It's different.
It's like I liked it that I liked that.
I liked classical music sometimes.
Man,
I liked it.
It exists,
but if I went to a Henry Rollins concert
or something like that and someone was
playing classical music,
I'd be like,
well,
this doesn't work.
Yeah.
You go see metallica and there's a
classical music band that opens up for
them.
You're like,
well,
okay.
Right.
Or the opposite.
They have to go on after like slayer,
slayer,
and then classical music.
Yeah.
What doesn't mean the classical music
sucks.
It means it's like right now it's not
the place for it.
It's not my frequency.
Right.
Want to fucking t bone.
So sometimes you want a fat porterhouse,
you know,
you want mashed potatoes and gravy and
sometimes you only want to sit down in
front of this guy has been working his
whole life on crafting the perfect kind
of sushi.
Correct.
And he's going to judge you while you
eat it.
Yeah.
This is going to serve you.
I love that.
Oh no.
You have to eat.
You need a certain way yet.
And he wants your response and then
delete.
Yeah.
A certain way.
What's a certain way?
Like I'm not sure man.
Who walks the dog?
He just gives it to you and you eat it.
no,
no.
So why did I,
w I was in Italy and I considered the,
the one that won the number one
restaurant in the world,
you know,
like initially and gives the,
gives an award to the best restaurant
once a year.
Right.
Woo.
And we actually sat with the chef and he
had like this,
like this thing comes out and it was a
bond was like this bond with eel like
barbecued eel.
You'd be like,
usually like,
what the fuck is this?
It was,
well when you,
when you bite into it,
you don't ever say,
oh that tastes just like,
you don't ever say that.
Well you don't even say that.
Tastes kind of like you just go.
Never smelled or tasted anything like
that in my life.
That's the most unique fucking flavor
and experience I've ever had.
And that's why he's always been in the
top for the past five years has been in
the top three best restaurants.
Finding sandwiches.
He makes the craziest shit.
He'll make a grilled cheese,
he'll make a grilled cheese and it's
like,
oh,
it's a grilled cheese.
Well,
no,
it's not actually,
it's what's called a perfect grilled
cheese
and then everything else is trying to be
a grilled cheese.
It's like,
that's.
That's good.
He'll do simple shit.
Little simple things and change your
whole fucking life.
Some bitch.
Nobody's changed my life with a fucking
grilled cheese sandwich was so ahead of
himself.
I'm just telling you so when you get
grilled.
So it's a fucking grilled cheese
sandwich.
Butter and jelly.
We had a sliding was a slider.
I had cheese sandwich once with short
ribs,
barbecued beef,
short ribs in it.
We should go eat.
Do those shorts that morton feldman with
Alex Jones.
Good lord.
They're good whole lee.
She's not as good as this guy.
You fuckers fox,
you don't know shit up.
This is why trump won.
People like you,
people like you and your fruity talking
about god damn elco neaten it and slave
served from Chad,
but it was cheap.
I mean,
any one of these,
if they gave you an option to buy the
phone in the United States,
but the phone might be a little more
wonky and cost 500 bucks more,
or you could just keep it going with
slave labor,
but I got to talk to my mother,
talking about the slave phone says,
I'll take that.
You're going to take that.
That's the one that's made in this
meticulous chinese factory by people
that make a pittance.
They do it right until someone who works
in America can enjoy their football game
on sunday and get their fucking coffee
break and by their ram truck and have a
good house in a suburbs.
You won't pay $500 more for your fucking
phone that you got attached to your hip
to give you bone cancer while you drive
your car.
You faggot american $500.
The exact same phone,
exact same exact 100 percent on 500
bucks.
Yeah.
Do you think the average person,
the average person would pay $50 more?
No,
I think $50 more as an achievable
number,
like $800.
Difference between the 800 and 1100 and
most of the time it's getting subsidized
by your cell phone company.
Most of the times,
like you buy a contract,
you get a phone for a discount,
like you buy an iphone from verizon or
what have you.
You're not spending the full 1200 bucks
or whatever it is at cost.
You're spending a part of that and the
rest of it gets paid off over the years
of your contract.
Yeah,
you can get a five year contract or
whatever you do,
but no one ever keeps the funnier it's
traded back in.
That restarts jack you back up and then
within a year so he can get a new phone
for free.
You can upgrade for free.
they want to keep you hooked to the
fucking tit.
some the things I don't see how you can
get better at certain things like I
don't like that tests out there.
I don't know how you make a better
technological car.
There'll be better.
For sure.
The first edition,
they'll well,
they'll have much more integrated
navigation systems,
navigation systems that have augmented
reality.
This is a big thing to do and now with
phones where they're coming up with
applications where you could hold a
phone up and you a little bit of a scan
your neighborhood and find out where the
stores are,
who could lift it up and like you can go
through the mall and it'll give you
reviews of each store.
Like augmented put balloons,
like cartoon balloons.
Like this is the juice factory.
They have awesome orange juice,
you know,
and won't point right there.
Ready?
Yep.
So this is going on right now.
like this is like ready to launch stuff.
Yeah.
So.
And this is just out of your phone,
just looking,
lifting up with your phone.
It's going to get in your car,
so that's going to be in your car.
There's going to be way better internet.
first of all,
like podcasts,
like the stuff that you guys are doing,
it's going to replace radio essentially
is going to be no reason to hire someone
to rent a building to broadcast a signal
when you can just get all the
information from,
whether it's our combat sports podcast
or news podcast or government.
It's going to be on the internet,
it's going to be like a direct line
right into your car.
It's ridiculous that it's not there on
every car already because it's free.
Like everybody wants something for free.
It's like it's right.
You can get it at any time.
That's going to be 100 percent the case.
It's going to be very difficult to sell
radio or even the idea of a radio signal
and just a few decades it's going to be.
It's going to be like Payphones.
Payphones don't exist anymore and be
like block.
The other thing that we were talking
about with manufacturing is I think it's
more likelY that we're going to end up
having a three d printers,
massive three d printers,
so we'll be able to order what we want.
That'll be made right in our,
in our jurisdiction and our town,
and then you know,
it's a.
It's a three minute drive to your house
with that or you come and pick it up at
this main depot.
Right?
Well,
they think that's the number one problem
with automated.
Like these artificially intelligent
computers and all the different things
they're going to have where they have
robots are building cars and shit.
The number one problem is going to be
the loss of jobs for skilled workers,
so all these people that are currently
doing these things like automated trucks
are going to replace truck drivers to
ups,
drivers,
truck drivers,
all that shake.
A bulk of a huge bulk of mosT male male
and blue collar employment is think they
can go from san francisco,
New York with no sleep.
I mean your packages,
they can't hit things that literally
they see have cameras all around the.
The backoff.
They've shown a diminished rate of
accidents with automated cars versus how
you're driving.
I drive my cAr,
my job,
but still not to do that though.
Do you ever do it?
You said it all the time.
Do pay attention or you just don't,
but I do.
I come to do that.
Could you put porn on that big flat
screen in front of you?
You got some guy died,
right?
So I've been doing it.
Yeah.
He's going to self-drive jacking off to
porn and died.
I'm pretty sure she imagine if that was
your shit,
like what do I like to do,
bro?
To get on the highway,
bring it up to about 75.
Sorry,
sarah pula.
do those people love to do things like
that in public?
Just all.
All he watches is gagging videos,
just likes running mascara and snotty
noses and blah,
and this guy's spitting on his own dick
on the highway.
Of course,
those window,
he's called brian count.
Can you jump in the back seat like can
you show now?
Apparently I think what was happening,
this is what I heard.
I don't know if it's true,
but guys would get drunk.
They would put there and that their
address into their navigation,
the take them home.
I don't know if that's.
And there'd be.
They crawl in the back seat and I think
tesla found out about that.
That's a big liability.
It's not ready.
It's not ready yet.
Yeah,
but if you let someone decide that they
can press automatic driver,
you can't decide when they compress it
and when they can.
Like either it can drive itself
perfectly or it can't.
It's got to get better,
but if you're drunk,
okay,
but if it does get better and you're
drunk,
is it irresponsible to let it drive
home?
No.
I mean it seems like it doesn't really
work.
Does it really work?
If it doesn't really work,
why the fuck do you sell in it?
Why are you selling automated car that
doesn't 100 percent of the time.
Every fucking single time work.
Not ready yet.
They shouldn't.
They shouldn't have released it.
When it can kind of work.
You currently can only do it if you're
in car pool.
If you're over 70 to case you gotta,
you gotta let drunk shabbat.
What happens to me is when I do self
drive,
sometimes it'll just stay.
Did you?
Are you amber?
We'll you can't or science.
You try to do it and go.
Not here.
like it won't work.
It tells you that you just can't.
You click the thing twice towards you
and sometimes it's not available.
it's like you have a freaky girlfriend,
but every now and then she turns you
down.
Just to give you that little element of
mystery,
like is it going to go down or is she
gonna get mad at me for no fucking
reason whatsoever.
Keeping you on your toes.
Goddamn this freaky bitch.
That's why don't we get done all these
tussles about.
I'm not really.
Don't like the tesla.
Well,
kids,
should we wrap this bitch up and fun.
I want everybody to know we didn't talk
about fights at all.
You.
Okay.
Let's go over to feel drained.
Drained,
germane to rhonda.
Me should have one or do you think that
she should have been deducted points?
She should've been it.
Worst case should have been a draw a.
I think the right thing to do was holly
should have won.
Even deducting those point.
You have to do that.
Those points and I think even germane
realized that when she goes,
I'll give holly a rematch right away
because tainted.
She's like,
I'm not a dirty fighter.
Like she knows what she did was fucked
up.
Only won that fight.
You think,
well,
well holly definitely got the only legit
knocked down.
You know,
she got that.
She landed that question mark kick.
That was beautiful.
Beautiful.
She hid it behind the shoulder,
came over the top planning.
I gave holly the wind for octagon
control,
let you landed more leg kicks and she
had the only significant strike in the,
like the big st,
like germain to random.
He did more damage when she connected,
but she didn't connect as much.
But then holly did do more damage in two
instances.
One with the question mark kick and
another time she dropped her with a
straight left.
Yes.
That was one of the best punches of the
fight and that was in the,
I think it was the fourth round last
round was.
IT might have been the fifth.
She dropped her and it was a.
It was a big moment.
So you could say that that and the head
kick round two different rounds or both?
Easily 10.
eight,
right.
You dropped him with a head kick and the
someone with you don't think so,
but you understand there's new rules.
The new rules will give them.
See which one?
Which one's off balance ahead.
No,
no,
no.
She said herself.
She was nasty,
she said herself.
She was days and there's a picture of it
on mike winkeljohn or jackson
winkeljohn.
John's a instagram account where you see
how well it connected.
It's over the top.
It's just shindig.
Don't do it.
She went down from that.
That was Legit.
But holly almost kicked her in the face
while she was down so she might've.
you're allowed to kick them in the chest
though.
What's interesting is like if she saw
that her hands were down,
she could've just changed the angle a
little bit and hit her.
He or she has the skill to do just a
good rule or a bad room.
I think the new one handed rule is
perfect.
I think that's perfect.
So what does that.
What does that one hands down you can
still kick them,
but if two hands or as soon as one hand
comes up,
you can kick him in the face.
But don't you think?
I think to get rid of it,
I gouging a hitting after the bell and
even growing kicks.
There's zero tolerance policy where if
it happens,
we got to the point 100 percent up to
the ref anymore because ralph's don't
want to change outcome with the fight.
So there they're so skewed to deduct a
point.
What she did to holly is ridiculous.
She's been twice already.
Too many fights.
She hit her so hard.
It changed outcome of the fight.
Yeah.
Holding onto one.
she rocked her with a giant righthand at
the end of the bell and it was bad.
It was bad to the point where we all
went,
oh,
like daniel cormier was next to me.
horrible.
It was the first time I did commentary
with cormier and uh,
an annex like the three of us together.
It was really good.
chromium was great.
It was interesting.
pens will kind of judge.
You got judged in the fight,
but some,
some judges would look at it the way you
guys are looking at based on what you
guys said.
And some would say the right way.
And then someone said,
yeah.
And then when others would look at it
like,
okay,
holly was trying to take her down,
look like she was avoiding the standup,
couldn't take her down,
she had her against the cage.
It was like some judges will look at
that as she doesn't want to fight
standing and she's not able to get the
fight to the ground.
She's kinda just holding against the
cage for safety.
Some people look at that as losing
around and not winning around.
You'll know what I mean.
she wants to get free.
It's octagon control.
She wants to get free and she can't get
free.
That been holly's holding her against
the rules.
That's the only way.
That's how they judge a fight.
That's one way to judge a fight.
The problem is is that that referee
didn't want to change that come to the
fight.
They're so scared of the backlash.
They don't.
They don't do it.
So you need to take that power out of
their hands and go.
Three was separating people when they
were clenching.
There's a lot more on the New York
should not Have those big fire.
You can't believe what you just said.
I'm surprised they let him even do that
title fight.
They have to.
It's New York state.
New york state is going to appoint their
own referees and a certain amount of
fights and I don't know how many.
I don't know how it works.
I don't know what the agreement is,
but that's often the case when you go
into state athletic commission,
the Joe Mccarthy,
herb dean levine,
you have to some of the best in the
world.
Mccarthy or herb dean come out and make
a statement and John John Mccarthy said,
uh,
they should have issued a warning bride
away,
like a strict warning on that first one,
which I disagree with,
and he goes on the second one,
I would have took a point.
They should take an appointment right
away.
Yeah,
I agree.
I agree for absolutely the second one,
but I think the first one was so
egregious crap,
boom combo to take the point.
I'm just not buying that,
that you know,
like I get the heat of the moment.
You can't let that happen.
I get that you're in the heat of the
moment,
you want to kill and destroy it and
you're to random me and you've got 46
million more tie and you're a 10 time
more thai champion cause you're a
fucking killer.
She's a killer man.
I mean that's what she is.
But there's a rule that was the rule.
You know,
you know what was going on,
you know what was going on.
You've been in 46 fights before that.
You never did that.
So all of a sudden you do in the heat of
the moment to see immediately,
twice immediate rematch.
That one $45.
Shit.
I think so.
I would say you have to have immediate
rematch too,
but germane to randomly look,
everybody knows the cyborg is looming in
the background.
You know,
cyborg is always going to be there.
There's no winner in this.
I mean holly should have one,
but you have to fight cyborg next.
Enjoy that.
Yeah.
It's,
it's to be really no winter.
It's going to be really interesting to
see what the choice is.
Whether or not to go straight to a
rematch or whether or not they let
cyborg five,
45 and nightmare for her to suck down to
know 40 years she's done 45 many times.
It's not easy.
Here's the deal.
As you get older and you do it more
often,
your body resists it more and more and
more and the fact that they make her.
I still maintain to this day,
they should have never asked her to go
to 1:40.
They should never have been trying to
get her to 1:35.
They should have just either have a
featherweight division or don't.
She said she could do it though.
Oh,
she's so crazy.
Met with her and she was like,
yeah,
we can do it.
So that's cool man.
There's so many fighters that that
dropped down a couple of weight classes.
That's a normal thing in mma.
So big.
So big brother.
You get smaller and smaller people.
Forty five,
48 class.
She could make 45.
She's done it before,
but even now,
like as people get older again,
like there's a lot.
It gets tougher and tougher and they
can't do it anymore.
You know?
Some guys just can't do it anymore.
Just hendrix is exactly the johnny.
This sunday we're doing a fight
companion or are we doing it?
Let's do it.
Oh sure.
You here sunday.
I'm going to be in nashville.
Nashville days.
Thursday,
friday,
saturday.
Everybody comes to me this weekend,
but then that sunday I fly back sunday
but I haven't seen my family in.
Okay.
We'll see him in the morning.
Make waffles and I'll see if I can do
what time?
probably 6:00.
I think 6:00
because it's 7:00.
People will freak out.
You got hector lumbar.
Johnny hendricks?
Yeah,
that's what I was gonna.
Say Johnny Hendricks fight and hector
lombard,
his first 185 pound fight that fight for
johnny.
It's not a good thing.
No,
goddamn lombard.
Looks so jacked right now.
I haven't seen a photo.
There was a photo of him like a
post-training,
like flexing his abs and I.
He so jack them at 85.
He can just eat whatever he wants to
cratejoy that Johnny Hendricks hendricks
is powerful and explosive and 85.
He never fought at 85.
He's had such a hard time sucking.
It's management.
Johnny five.
Jesus fucking christ.
One person who wants that guy.
He's so jack.
He's lost his last two though.
Yeah,
but he lost a damn fucking henderson and
who you lose two before that.
Oh,
the old magnet magnet.
Neil magazine was oppressive because he
had neil magnet out.
Amazing.
Crazy.
That was amazing.
You look how tough neil magnet has to be
to survive the onslaught of that first
round.
Like he got cry.
He wants to fight with jorge mas.
We don't know what the fun one,
but it's in my head of him in the
rankings.
Now he is.
He got his shot at number five.
Why can't you know?
Neil's ranked seven or eighth.
Why can't you get a shot?
Here's the fight to set up mazda doll
versus damien maia for the number one
contender,
but this fucked up to damien has already
got damien's only one though.
Number one it because they have to have
this fucking rematch.
Robbie,
lots of good mac.
That's a good match because he probably
laughed bad blood this summer and
they'll black.
No bang.
Help those two.
Hold on.
Wouldn't you rather see cowboy versus
robbie lawler?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Know what?
I don't want to see it anytime soon.
Cowboy,
take a goddamn break.
How much of a time?
At least six months.
Six months.
Six months,
no training,
no.
In pursuit of the title right now.
It's kind of chill.
It's got nothing to prove.
He's amazing.
He's done this thing.
I wonder if there's a way where you can
tell how long a guy should take off
after they get a severe knockout.
Like a wonder if there's tests that they
can do where they can tell you,
you know,
you fuck up your meniscus,
they give you a scope and they go look.
Just be real easy on it.
Exactly.
Yeah.
They have like a time limit and they can
look at it and then they can do an mri
afterwards.
Hey,
you're looking good brendon.
So we're going to authorize some light
training,
but please take it easy.
Let's see how we can do it.
The reaction drill.
Kenny,
did they do it?
Uh,
it's a test reaction to in football we
used to do,
if you've got concussed you,
uh,
before the season you do the test,
see how fast you are,
and then if you got concussed,
they make you do it.
See how fast you go.
Whoa.
And then you do it two weeks later to
see what is it comprised of?
Uh,
it's like,
it's like the,
all these different objects and you have
to touch it when they blink and then
you've got to put patterns together.
Oh wow.
Oh,
lIke,
sorta like that.
What was that game?
Simon?
Yay.
There you go simon.
But with shapes,
shapes and colors,
and then you'd have a certain timeline
if you didn't.
Forty six seconds.
If you're a concussion,
did in two minutes,
is it two weeks later you're back to
your normal.
that's really interesting that we have
it that way because some people would
argue that there's some stupid
motherfuckers out there.
It doesn't matter if they're concussed,
there's still going to suck at that
worst than you are.
Well,
If they say,
let me back,
and guys a moron,
he can't remember his own fucking name
and you let him play every week.
We're shooting coach.
I'm sure there's better ways brain we
just can't get into.
But that's the thing is,
is not better ways.
one of the scariest things about cte is
they can't really,
really check to see what you have until
after dead.
How is that the case?
How come they can't see that with mris
is that mri just aren't as effective yet
that matter doesn't show up,
does it?
There are a lot of issues in the mris
they did.
They did an mri on a dead salmon and
certain parts of the brain lit up.
So you got to be very obvious.
Jesus,
maybe,
maybe it's gone,
don't necessarily tell you,
uh,
like when they say,
oh,
this part of your brain lit up when you
were doing this,
when you were thinking about this,
this a little bit misleading,
it's not.
Why is that like a shock that like some
area of their brain,
even though the body's dead might have
some weird connection to the great
beyond while they're sitting there at
the fulton fish market on a pile of ice,
like there's some part of their brain
tuning into the god force of the
universe and we just say it's over four
men.
Look no gills.
We already go to him.
It's over and he's there and his little
fucking fish head traveling through
dimensions.
I always wondered why when they cut your
head off,
when,
when to kill a tree,
when they cut your head off,
they'd see people mouthing prayers while
they were still doing it.
Good.
So as you are you conscious of your
brain as oxygen,
you get your head cut off right away,
but who are you looking?
Is it possible for your head and your
brain to be looking at your headless
body?
For sure.
No,
it is.
Here's the deal because when you head
gets cut off,
the blood's not pumping through your
head.
It's gonna.
Stay there.
Okay.
Your second.
Just some of it's going to spill out.
whatever's there is going to carry
oxygen to your fucking stupid brain for
as long as you stay alive and it's only
gonna be a few seconds,
so if you're lying there and there's
still blood in your brain,
you're looking over at your head,
you're like,
oh my god,
and coming out of your mouth because
you're not attached to your lungs
anymore.
Yeah,
that's what they did.
Shot in the heart.
You die like right away,
like you have all those.
No,
you don't.
You don't die right away.
You guys really quickly.
Your body takes a few seconds.
it takes a few seconds,
but if he had a shotgun,
just blow a hole through your chest.
You would.
You wouldn't be alone.
In Texas.
You still get the oxygenated blood in
your brain.
Although when you get your,
your,
your head blown off the road when you're
going to be severed that quickly.
It doesn't knock you out though
sometimes.
I'm sure in some cases there were there
they said that the the size of the head
would still be mouthing prayers as it
was.
I can only imagine,
man.
It was just always a well known that
when you her head cut off to be saying
things,
but I bet there's a book called a
history of the guillotine.
Could you have imagined this doctor?
Imagine being a town square.
They decided some fucking pickpocket
needs to get his head caught off in
front of everybody and get to see.
That was the containment.
I know,
but how crazy is that?
Imagine watching
that big thing dropped down on someone's
head and the fucking head hit the
basket.
We're still in to it.
Those ices vetoes are bigger than
effort.
It's more views than ever.
Didn't Mississippi?
Just it.
Was it Mississippi?
They just passed a law allowing firing
squad executions.
Again,
that's some redneck shit.
Sipping.
I think it might be Mississippi.
Every message y'all.
Are they having problems getting the
medicine or the.
Yeah,
so they just plenty of bullets down
there.
Fuck it mean it is kind of weird that
there's like a good way in a bad way to
kill.
People still have public executions and
they had the guy,
they're really the sword and he comes
out and you brought out and I believe
you're there,
you're,
somebody says a blessing over you.
You were able to say some prayers and
then I believe my dad witnessed this a
couple times.
It's a public thing.
And you squat down.
Dad witnessed this.
Yeah,
because there's officers right there.
You get on your knees.
So he's just sat up there.
And why did he go out and watch it?
He could actually see some of it from
his window.
Apparently his office window but prime
spot.
But yes,
he was there and he saw it and my mother
saw it too.
And so the guy would be his hands,
I believe were tied behind.
His back is forced to squat and what
they'll do is if they're good,
they'll jab you a little bit.
So you stiffen and then boom,
really quickly the head comes off.
so they jab me in the back and they say
your body so you don't sway.
So here,
you know,
and then it comes right off.
Or they still do.
They still have the death penalty in
California.
Um,
last ad they do,
but they haven't killed anybody here in
quite a while.
We're these the kill people with gas
chambers is the most evil,
not extra city electricity when it
doesn't work.
What's weird is that like real violence,
like bullets is what we frowned upon the
real effective way.
Like shooting someone that had put a
gun.
Right.
Blow it away.
Yeah.
The most cheapest,
easiest way for some.
That's ridiculous.
It should attend humane for sure.
What works.
But so a gas chamber is supposed to be
humane.
I'm saying shoot him.
It's obviously cheaper than the way to
go.
Are they doing,
are they using the gas chamber because I
try to be humane or,
or are they trying to be evil?
Get figure out a way to do it where it
seems more systematic than a bullet will
also be more injections.
So I think now lethal injection is the
most common.
Was the gas chamber,
is that,
was it to be humane in California or is
it to be an evil and we're going to get
revenge on you?
Kill.
I believe that public execution,
as it was done in this country,
whether it was through anything,
whether it was hanging,
whether it was electric chair,
whether it was gas chamber,
there was always the idea that it was
supposed to be done at least by the
state in a dignified manner,
not enough,
not,
not in a way that constitutes cruel and
unusual punishment.
For example,
what's,
what's uh,
so you would never talk to somebody to
death.
You try to make it as quickly as
possible,
as systematic as possible.
The state says you have to die.
You give your life up for the crime.
You committed an eye for an eye and
that's done in a very sort of
antiseptic,
systematic way,
but you fucked up.
You know,
you fucked up when you're strapped to a
chair and you're looking up and all the
people that were friends with the person
who killed are staring at you and
they're about to cook.
You go about to fucking screw this
electrical down on your bed.
You can't listen to even more fucked up,
but you can't see them.
I think the reason they don't shoot you
in the head is to that you know the
family.
If the family wants to have an open
casket,
funeral and all that goes out the window
if you killed.
No,
it's.
We know what's really fucked up.
The whole thing was that they give you
your choice of what you get to eat.
Oh yeah.
You get a last meal.
You get to pick your last meal.
Oh yeah,
you can fuck you in ell sandwich.
We keys and shit yet man.
Kevin,
nice beer and ice cold beer with it.
This guy asked me,
how would you like to go if you had a
choice?
Electric chair,
gas chamber or lethal injection.
Packable greens,
so that in there as well.
Lethal injection because they put you to
sleep.
first 50 will run.
What about between electric chair or gas
chamber?
Fuck,
I don't know.
Electric.
You have to choose one.
Fuck.
Come on.
Get off the table.
You,
you,
you go into convulsions.
You foam at the mouth.
I like how they have to hit you again.
Sometimes hit them again with the
electric chair.
It didn't work and they tried it twice.
It didn't work on the dude and now they
can't kill them.
Do you bleed to death?
We talked about this before.
Those killings and faces of death.
Some of them are definitely.
They're all real creation.
Some of them are definitely real.
There was a really,
really real one where they have this guy
from the middle east.
They tied them to two different trucks
and pull them apart.
That shit's real documentary.
It was on youtube that set the whole.
It was about the guys who put it
together.
They're being interviewed.
The guys,
they'll do everything and they show you
how they did the monkey brain.
They said,
oh,
that's definitely fake.
It's all fake.
All of it.
Where they eddie,
but it had.
Hold on a second 80.
That's not true because like that
fucking judge shot himself on
television.
What's that guy's name from that song?
Hey man.
Nice shot dwyer,
dwyer.
That guy is in faces of death and that
guy really shut the fucking ones.
I don't remember which one he was in.
I saw something with the guys who put it
together,
that directors or they put it together,
they're talking about different people
in the scenes and they're going through
it,
but there's a guy who jumped off and he
definitely.
That was a lot of people that dIed.
I think the whole thing was faked.
It all knows my child.
No,
they didn't see.
They had some real footage and some fake
foot is.
They have some real live events.
I saw a documentary about each scene.
Oh,
then we'll just chalk that up.
Is true.
It was on youtube though.
I do.
I'll admit that will lend it to know
that it's already 6:30
for got sick.
I take care of my dog.
Take your dog.
So sunday fight companion,
6:00
PM pacific time for travis browne vs
derrick lewis and hector lombard versus
Johnny Hendricks.
Those are actually two pretty good
fIghts.
That should be interesting.
So that sunday,
hugh fox.
Bye everybody.